One of my favorite things to do with my family is to go on a road trip. We are road trippers. Josh and I love to pack up the car and hit the road with our kids. And I just love the sense of adventure of exploring new places. And we love to use Airbnb. We love staying in a home. We love having a kitchen, having some type of backyard, our patio to sit on at night.
我和家人最喜欢做的事情之一就是去自驾游。我们是一群自驾游爱好者。乔什和我喜欢收拾好行李，和孩子们一起踏上旅程。我只是喜欢探索新地方的那种冒险感。而且我们喜欢用 Airbnb。我们喜欢住在家里。我们喜欢有个厨房，有个能晚上坐在上面的那种后院或露台。
I love the privacy of it. And also it just feels like you're still at home even though you're on this adventure because you make your own home. And you know, Airbnb is just so great for families because you can really pick a place that suits your whole group. You know, we did that one year with my family.
我喜欢它的私密性。而且它也让人感觉你依然身处家中，尽管你正在经历这场冒险，因为你创造了自己的家。你知道，Airbnb 对家庭来说真是太棒了，因为你真的可以挑选一个适合你们整个团队的地方。你知道，有那么一年我和我的家人就是这么做的。
We all met up in the mountains and picked this great Airbnb and all stayed in it together. Cousins and nieces and nephews and aunts and uncles. It was so much fun and it was so cozy. And Airbnb really made that family memory special. So use Airbnb for your next adventure. Where's your playlist taking you? Down the highway? To the mountains? next adventure. List is a great trip. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Book, direct, and save at bestwestern.com. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
我们都在山里聚首，选了这个棒极了的 Airbnb，然后大家一起住在里面。表亲、侄女、侄子、阿姨和叔叔。真的太有趣了，而且非常温馨。Airbnb 真的让那个家庭记忆变得特别。所以下一次冒险就用 Airbnb 吧。你的播放列表带你去哪儿了？沿着高速公路？去山里？下一次冒险。列表是一次美妙的旅行。生活就是一趟旅程。在贝斯特韦斯特酒店尽情享受吧。在 bestwestern.com 直接预订并省钱。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。
We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi, I'm sorry.
我们一起拍过《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的办公室爱好者播客。每周我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量 VFF 故事，深入探讨办公室的世界。我们是 Office Lady 6.0。嗨，对不起。
I'm so sorry. Yep, I did it. Jenna, okay, I don't even I'm so sorry. Um, yep. I did it. Jenna, okay, I don't even know where to start. Okay, first of all, for Christmas, Sam gave us each a sweatshirt. Like an ugly Christmas sweatshirt. Yeah, but they're all Keanu Reeves in some situation. Yeah. Like mine says Merry Wickmas. Thank you, Sam. Jenna Warhurst today, you guys, and I wasn't prepared for it to be right across from me this whole time. It
非常抱歉。没错，我做到了。珍娜，好吧，我甚至——我非常抱歉。嗯，没错。我做到了。珍娜，好吧，我甚至不知道该从哪里开始。好吧，首先，圣诞节时，山姆送了我们每人一件卫衣。就像丑陋的圣诞卫衣那种。是的，但上面全都是基努·里维斯在各种情境下的形象。是的。比如我那件写着“威克圣诞快乐”。谢谢你，山姆。今天珍娜·沃赫斯特，你们大家，我一点也没有准备好它这会儿就正对着我。这
is Keanu is like maybe a patron saint. Yep. And he's holding a dog, a little dog, like he's rescued a dog, but he's like a saint. He has like the halo thing. How do you feel about looking into his sweet eyes? He's looking off. He's he's like a saint. He has like the halo thing. How do you feel about looking into his sweet eyes? He's looking off. He's not looking right at you. He's gazing that way, but he is right on your chest. Yeah, here's the thing. I love this sweatshirt. You walked through the streets in this. You got in your car. Oh, not just that. Oh, yeah. Well, you should tell them.
是基努就像是守护神一样。是的。他抱着一只狗，一只小狗，就像他救了一只狗一样，但他就像个圣人。他有那种光环一样的东西。你看着他那双温柔的眼睛感觉如何？他正看着别处。他——他就像个圣人。他有那种光环一样的东西。你看着他那双温柔的眼睛感觉如何？他正看着别处。他没有直接看着你。他正凝视着那个方向，但他就在你的胸口。是的，事情是这样的。我超爱这件卫衣。你穿着它走在街上。你上了车。哦，不仅如此。哦，是的。嗯，你应该告诉他们。
I had a morning. She told me, OK, she said, Ange, I'm going to wear kind of a fun outfit today. I'm going to surprise you. And we haven't shared with you, we're doing subtle sexuality today. And I thought, oh, I bet she's coming in a gold leotard. Oh, no.
我今天过得真丰富。她告诉我，好吧，她说，安琪，我今天要穿一套挺有意思的服装。我要给你个惊喜。我们还没跟你分享，我们主要在搞低调性感。我想，哦，我敢打赌她会穿着金色紧身衣来。哦，不。
No. This is what you think. You thought I was going to dress like subtle sexuality? Oh, I bet she's coming in gold leotard. Oh no, Mike, no! This is what you think, you thought I was gonna dress like subtle sexuality? Yes, because I considered doing it, but then I didn't. I did, but I didn't have time. And then I had an old leotard and I put it on and you know what, it hugged things in all the wrong spots. Well, I wanted to wear this because I love it and I don't care that it's Christmas themed. The holidays are over, but I didn't get to wear it in the holidays. So I'm going to wear it today.
不。这就是你的想法。你以为我要打扮成低调性感的样子？哦，我敢打赌她会穿着金色紧身衣来。哦不，迈克，不！这就是你的想法，你以为我要打扮成低调性感的样子？是的，因为我有考虑过这么做，但后来我没穿。我穿了，但我没时间。然后我有一件旧紧身衣，我把它穿上了，你知道吗，它把肉勒在了所有错误的地方。好吧，我想穿这个是因为我喜欢它，我才不在乎它是不是圣诞主题的呢。假期已经结束了，但我没能在假期里穿。所以我要今天穿。
I'm bringing that energy into the new year. But just say you thought you were just getting in your car and driving to the studio. And then we all got a text on the way here. Sorry to laugh, lady. But you said, oh no, I've got a flat tire. Yeah. I was about to get on the highway and I saw my tire gauge go red. It was almost flat. I had enough time to stop, fill it
我要把这种活力带入新的一年。但只要说你以为你只是上车然后开车去工作室。然后我们在来的路上都收到了一条短信。抱歉笑出来，女士。但你说，哦不，我爆胎了。是的。我正准备上高速公路，然后我看到我的胎压表变红了。它快没气了。我有足够的时间停下来，给它
with air and then drive it to the tire place. Where you met several folks that work at the tire place wearing this Keanu piece. I did. So let me tell you something. They got me fixed up in 20 minutes. And I think it's thanks to Keanu because when I walked up and I said, hey, I got my tire, I think is... Can I please take your picture so people know what you look like right now? He pointed at my sweatshirt and he laughed and he said, that is amazing. Oh, I love it.
充气，然后把它开到轮胎店。在那里你遇到了几个在轮胎店工作、穿着这件基努衣服的人。是的。所以让我告诉你一件事。他们20分钟就帮我修好了。而且我认为这要归功于基努，因为当我走过去说，嘿，我的轮胎，我想是……我能拍张你的照片好让人知道你现在长什么样吗？他指着我的卫衣笑了笑，说，这太棒了。哦，我太喜欢了。
And we were just, we hit it off from the beginning. So clearly Keanu, he was looking out for you today. My patron saint, Keanu. Yeah. They saw the sweatshirt. They're like, this lady needs help. Was an office fan as well. Oh, told him about our podcast, took a photo. I told him I throw it up in our stories since he was my hero of the day. Oh, amazing.
而且我们从一开始就一见如故。所以显然基努，他今天一直在关照你。我的守护神，基努。是的。他们看到了卫衣。他们觉得，这位女士需要帮助。也是个办公室迷。哦，把我们的播客告诉了他，拍了张照。我告诉他我要把它发到我们的快拍里，因为他是我的今日英雄。哦，太棒了！
Well, listen, that wasn't gonna be my top of show share today. I actually have a fun one. If you don't mind taking another minute. I saw this meme lady. What? I saw meme. Remember memes? What are they again? It's not like a picture with words on them. OK, it's not a gif. No, it doesn't move.
好吧，听着，那本来不是我今天要分享的节目头条。我其实有一个很有趣的分享。如果你不介意再花一分钟的话。我看到了这个表情包，女士。什么？我看到了表情包。还记得表情包吗？它们到底是什么来着？它不就像是一张带字的图片吗。好吧，它不是动图。不，它不会动。
And it says that what you should do to find out your fortune for the year 2025 is you should look up what movie was number one at the box office when you turned 10 years old. And that movie is like your fortune for the year. Gosh, when I was 10, I was in Indonesia. I have no idea what the movies were. I looked up all of our birthdays
上面说，要想算出你在 2025 年的运势，你应该查一查当你满 10 岁时，哪部电影是票房冠军。那部电影就像是你的年度运势。天哪，我 10 岁的时候，我在印度尼西亚。我根本不知道当时有什么电影。我查了我们所有人的生日
and I can tell you everyone's fortune for the year. Really? Mm-hmm. All right, Angela, your movie is Superman 2. Oh. And in Superman 2, Superman gives up his powers to live a normal life with Lois Lane at the exact same time that three big villains
，我可以告诉你每个人的年度运势。真的吗？嗯哼。好吧，安吉拉，你的电影是《超人 2》。哦。而在《超人 2》中，超人放弃了超能力，与露易丝·莱恩过上了正常的生活，与此同时，三个大反派
are let onto the planet. The ones dressed all in black? Yes, and they don't have their, he doesn't have his powers. They were like in a little triangle, but like an asteroid hit it or something, and they all came to Earth. They all came to Earth, you remember it.
被放到了地球上。全穿着黑衣服的那几个？是的，而且他们没有他们的，他没有他的超能力。他们好像在一个小三角形里，但好像一颗小行星击中了它什么的，然后他们都来到了地球。他们都来到了地球，你还记得。
So listen, Ange, I think the moral here is do not give up your superpowers this year to live a normal life. We need you. Done. Okay? Well, I'll keep my superpowers at party planning and scrapbooking and taking pictures of plants on my walk. We need this.
所以听着，安琪，这里的道德寓意我想是今年千万不要放弃你的超能力去过正常的生活。我们需要你。搞定。好吗？好吧，我会把我的超能力留给派对策划、制作剪贴簿以及在散步时拍植物的照片。我们需要这个。
Wait, does Superman like to eat? Because I do have some superpowers in the kitchen and I wasn't sure where to share this, but I have a really big fun share. Yes, oh, you have to share this, Angela. Sharing is one of your superpowers. Do it! All right, well, this is an exclusive.
等等，超人喜欢吃东西吗？因为我在厨房里确实有一些超能力，我不知道该在哪里分享这个，但我有一个非常棒、非常有趣的分享。是的，哦，你一定要分享这个，安吉拉。分享是你的超能力之一。快分享！好吧，这是一个独家。
I'm sharing with you all first. Those of you guys that have been listening to the podcast and following us for all these years know that my husband, Josh, is an amazing baker and cook. And he and I have been working on a cookbook for the last year and a half. And guess what? I can finally tell you the name of it
我先跟你们所有人分享。你们这些听了播客并关注我们这么多年的小伙伴都知道，我的丈夫乔什是一位出色的烘焙师和厨师。他和我在过去一年半里一直在合作一本食谱书。你猜怎么着？我终于可以告诉你它的名字了
and you can order it. Guess what the name is? You already know Jenna. I'm looking at you like guests, but you're like, I already know. It's called, You Can Make This. And I love this title because Josh came up with it. It's sort of a little inside joke with our family
，你可以预订了。你猜名字是什么？你已经知道了，珍娜。我看着你们就像看嘉宾一样，但你们的表情就像是，我已经知道了。它叫《你也能做这个》。我喜欢这个名字，因为是乔什想出来的。这算是我们家里的一个小内部笑话
because whenever me and the kids are trying to tackle a recipe, he makes it so simple for us and he'll look at us and say, you can make this. And these recipes are so special. Josh has really been thoughtful about picking them. They are our family favorites. And there's really something for everyone in the cookbook.
，因为每当我和孩子们试图攻克一个食谱时，他总是把它变得对我们来说很简单，他会看着我们说，你也能做这个。这些食谱非常特别。乔什在挑选它们时真的很用心。它们是我们全家的最爱。而且食谱里真的适合每个人。
There's meals, side snacks, yummy desserts, and the recipes are simple, delicious, and guess what? You can make this. You can make this. I can make this, I've made this. You've made this. I make Josh's recipes all the time. I do his baking recipes, I do his one sheet meals. Oh my gosh, he's got soups. I know, he loves the time. I do his baking recipes, I do his one sheet meals.
这里有正餐、配菜小吃、美味的甜点，而且食谱简单、美味，你猜怎么着？你也能做这个。你也能做这个。我能做这个，我做过这个。你做过这个。我经常做乔什的食谱。我做他的烘焙食谱，我做他的单盘烤箱菜。哦天哪，他还会做汤。我知道，他太喜欢了。我做他的烘焙食谱，我做他的单盘烤箱菜。
Oh my gosh, he's got soups. I know, he is a great cook. Well, I'm so proud of it. And you know, we took the photo that's on the book cover in our home and I'll put a swipe up where you can pre-order cause that's a big deal. Yes.
哦天哪，他还会做汤。我知道，他是个很棒的厨师。嗯，我为此感到骄傲。而且你知道，书封上的那张照片是我们自己家里拍的，我会放一个向上滑动的链接，你们可以去预订，因为这可是件大事。是的。
The pre-sales are kind of what set the book apart to succeed. So if you guys go and pre-order, I would love you so much. And I promise you're gonna love the cookbook. I promise you're gonna love it too. All right, Ange, I loved that. And now, Sam, it's your turn. Yes.
预售可以说是决定一本书能否成功的关键。所以如果你们去预订，我会非常爱你们的。我向你们保证，你们一定会喜欢这本食谱。我向你们保证，你们也一定会喜欢它。好了，安琪，我很喜欢那个。现在，山姆，轮到你了。是的。
Here's yours. Okay. D2, The Mighty Ducks. Oh, all right. Oh. Emilia Estevez? Yep. Yes. Yep. That's a good movie.
这是你的。好的。《野鸭变凤凰2》。哦，好吧。哦。埃利奥特·伊斯泰维兹？ Yep. 是的。没错。那是一部好电影。
Yep, and here's what happens in that. You know, they're high on their wins, so they're kind of leaning into their fame. OK. And they have to get back into training so that they can take on Iceland. Oh. So I don't know what this is, Sam, but I think Iceland's
是的，这里面发生的事情是这样的。你知道，他们因为连赢而洋洋得意，所以他们有点沉浸在名气中。好吧。他们不得不重新开始训练，以便迎战冰岛队。哦。所以我不知道这是什么，山姆，但我认为冰岛
coming for you. OK, I'm going back to audio engineering school. Just, you know. To learn podcasts. Because someone in Iceland is coming for us. Okay, great, I look forward to meeting you. Okay, Cassie, your film is Liar Liar. Hey, that's a great one.
冲你来了。好吧，我要回音频工程学校了。只是，你知道的。去学做播客。因为冰岛有人冲我们来了。好吧，太好了，我很期待见到你。好的，卡茜，你的电影是《大话王》。嘿，那部很棒！
So I think this year you won't be able to tell a lie and this will lead to hilarious hijinks for you. You know what, let's do it. This is the year Cassie burns it to the ground. We're gonna have a segment called Get Real with Cassie. And mine is Footloose. Oh, that's a great one. Yeah, I actually, I turned it on this morning
所以我觉得今年你将无法说谎，这会为你带来滑稽搞笑的恶作剧。你知道吗，那就来吧。今年是卡茜把一切付之一炬的一年。我们将有一个环节叫“与卡茜面对现实”。而我的是《浑身是劲》。哦，那部很棒！是的，我其实，我今天早上把它打开了
and watched a little bit of it with my breakfast. You're gonna go against the system, lady? I don't know. Here's what I think. I'm going to have a year of political and social drama, lots of stressful situations coming at me constantly, all of which can be solved with a little dancing. You're going to dance through this year, lady. I'm dancing through.
，边吃早饭边看了一小段。你要跟体制对抗吗，女士？我不知道。我的想法是这样的。我要过一年充满政治和社会戏剧性的生活，身边不断有许多压力重重的状况向我袭来，而所有这一切都可以通过一小段舞蹈来解决。你今年要一路跳舞闯过去，女士。我要跳着过去。
Whatever comes your way, you're going to dance through it. It's not going to be easy, but I'm dancing through it. Yeah. And I'll say I loved having a little side of Kevin Bacon with my eggs this morning. Oh, honey. See what I did there?
无论有什么迎面扑来，你都要一路跳舞闯过去。这不会容易，但我会跳着过去的。是的。而且我要说，我今天早上很喜欢在鸡蛋旁边加一点凯文·贝肯。哦，亲爱的。明白我什么意思吗？
You did a dad pun. You did it. I wore Keanu, but this Christmas, Sam, maybe it's Kevin Bacon? Maybe Kevin Bacon on a sweatshirt? I'll put the word out. Thank you. Okay.
你开了一个冷笑话。你做到了。我穿了基努，但这个圣诞节，山姆，也许是凯文·贝肯？也许卫衣上印凯文·贝肯？我把这个消息放出去。谢谢。好的。
All right, that's it. Well, that was a fun meme. Yeah, so everyone, you can find out what your fortune is for the year by finding out what movie was number one at the box office when you turned 10 years old. Have fun. Well, speaking of dancing,
好了，就这些。嗯，那真是一个有趣的表情包。是的，所以每个人，你可以通过查阅当你 10 岁时哪部电影是票房冠军，来找出你今年的运势。祝你们玩得开心。嗯，说到跳舞，
we have a really fun episode this week. It is the web series, Subtle Sexuality, and the follow-up music video, Girl Next Door. Yes! This webisode starred Mindy Kaling, B.J. Novak, Ellie Kemper, Oscar Nunez, Ed Helms, and Brian Baumgartner. Here's a little summary for you. Kelly and Erin form a girl group called Subtle Sexuality and they produce their first music video for their song Male Prima Donna. The music video stars the two of them, Anne, Ryan, and Andy. Oscar is annoyed and Kevin is looking for a way to participate. And these are really fun. They are so fun. I wish they would have aired like regularly. Oh, I have a fan comment about that later. Okay. Well, we have a ton of great
我们这周有一集非常有趣的节目。那就是网络剧《低调性感》，以及后续的音乐录影带《隔壁女孩》。耶！这部网络剧由敏迪·卡灵、B·J·诺瓦克、艾丽·坎珀、奥斯卡·努涅斯、埃德·赫尔姆斯和布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳主演。这里有一个小结供大家参考。凯利和艾琳组建了一个名为“低调性感”的女子组合，并为她们的歌曲《男万人迷》制作了她们的第一支音乐录影带。音乐录影带的主演是她俩、瑞恩和安迪。奥斯卡很烦恼，凯文则在寻找参与的方式。这些真的很有趣。它们太有趣了。我真希望它们能像常规剧集那样播出。哦，我稍后有一个关于这的粉丝评论。好吧。嗯，我们有很多超棒的
behind the scenes stuff for this webisode series. I want to give a big thank you just right out of the gate to Joya Balfour, who was at NBC Digital at the time. She gave us so much scoop. I can't wait to sprinkle it throughout this episode. She really did. She really came through. So you guys remember when we shared about the accountants webisode, we talked about how incredibly popular these webisodes were.
关于这个网络剧系列的幕后花絮。我首先要对乔亚·巴尔福表示诚挚的谢意，她当时在 NBC Digital 工作。她给我们提供了如此多的内幕消息。我等不及要在本集中穿插讲述了。她真的很给力。她真的说到做到。所以你们还记得当我们分享关于会计师网络剧的那集时，我们谈到这些网络剧是多么的受欢迎。
I mean, groundbreaking, award-winning. Well, subtle sexuality continued the trend. Subtle sexuality ran on both NBC.com and Hulu. And Joya Balfour told us, to this day, Subtle Sexuality remains the most streamed web series of any scripted show on NBC. And it beat all but three of the network's full episodes during its first week online. It also became a number one music video on iTunes and the number four single. I know.
我是说，开创性的，获奖的。嗯，低调性感延续了这一趋势。低调性感在 NBC.com 和 Hulu 上播放。乔亚·巴尔福告诉我们，直到今天，“低调性感”仍然是 NBC 任何有剧本节目中播放量最高网络剧。它在上线的第一周就击败了该电视网除了三集之外的所有完整剧集。它还成为了 iTunes 上的第一名音乐录影带和第四名单曲。我知道。
Listen to this, Joya sent us a screen grab she took when this single hit. It's the top 10 songs on iTunes in October of 2009 when the webisodes premiered. I just wanna read you where it landed. I want you to hear who all was in that top 10. Ready? Yeah.
听着这个，乔亚给我们发了一张她在这首单曲上榜时截的屏幕截图。那是 2009 年 10 月网络剧首播时 iTunes 上的前 10 名歌曲。我只想读一下它落脚的位置。我想让你们听听那前 10 名里都有谁。准备好了吗？是的。
The number one song was 15 by Taylor Swift. Number two, Thriller by Michael Jackson. That always resurfaces around October. Okay. Number three, Party in the USA by Miley Cyrus. Number four, Mel Primadonna by Subtle Sexuality. Number five was Meet Me Halfway by Black Eyed Peas. Number six, One Less Lonely Girl by Justin Bieber.
第一名是泰勒·斯威夫特的《15》。第二名是迈克尔·杰克逊的《Thriller》。那首歌在 10 月前后总是会重新出现。好的。第三名是麦莉·赛勒斯的《Party in the USA》。第四名是《低调性感》的《男万人迷》。第五名是黑眼豆豆的《Meet Me Halfway》。第六名是贾斯汀·比伯的《One Less Lonely Girl》。
Number seven, Fireflies by Owl City. Number eight was Five Star by Yo Gotti. Number nine, You Belong to Me by Taylor Swift. Number 10, You Belong to Me by Taylor Swift. Mel Prim to me by Taylor Swift. Number 10, you belong to me by Taylor Swift. Mel Prima Donna beat Taylor Swift. Well Taylor Swift beat Mel Prima Donna, but then Mel Prima Donna beat Taylor Swift. But Mel Prima Donna also beat Justin Bieber. I mean, this is, can you believe it?
第七名是猫头鹰之城的《Fireflies》。第八名是约·高蒂的《Five Star》。第九名是泰勒·斯威夫特的《You Belong to Me》。第十名是泰勒·斯威夫特的《You Belong to Me》。男万人击败了泰勒·斯威夫特。好吧，泰勒·斯威夫特击败了男万人，但后来男万人击败了泰勒·斯威夫特。但男万人也击败了贾斯汀·比伯。我是说，这，你们能相信吗？
No, that's crazy. So you know, with the success of the Accountants webisodes, this time around NBC knew that they were going to get a huge audience so they went all out. When it premiered they had a home page takeover of NBC.com. The first thing that landed was Subtle Sexuality if you went to NBC.com. Wow. They also built a separate website for Subtle Sexuality and this webisode series was featured in Entertainment Weekly and in Us Weekly. And Joya sent us the Entertainment Weekly photo
不，这太疯狂了。所以你知道，随着《会计师》网络剧的成功，这一次 NBC 知道他们将获得巨大的观众群，所以他们全力以赴了。首播时，他们在 NBC.com 上进行了首页接管。如果你去 NBC.com，首先映入眼帘的就是《低调性感》。哇。他们还为《低调性感》建立了一个独立的网站，这个网络剧系列还被《娱乐周刊》和《美国周刊》报道过。乔亚给我们发了《娱乐周刊》的照片
with the little blurb. So I'll share that in stories. I'm gonna be sharing a ton in stories this week. And they also had a ton of fun with merchandise. They had custom CD designs, lyrics and liner notes, downloadable band posters, fan giveaways, t-shirts. They went all out. Well fans couldn't get enough of this Erin and Kelly storyline. They even had a follow-up song and music video Girl
以及一小段简介。所以我会在快拍里分享。我这周会在快拍里分享大量内容。而且他们在周边商品上也玩得很开心。他们有定制的 CD 设计、歌词和内页说明、可下载的乐队海报、粉丝赠品、T 恤。他们真的全力以赴了。嗯，粉丝们对艾琳和凯莉的这条故事线百看不厌。他们甚至还有一首后续歌曲和音乐录影带《隔壁女孩
Next Door. You can still watch all of this on Peacock and NBC.com. They have both. I also really liked Girl Next Door. It's really catchy. Mm-hmm. Yeah. I mean, we'll get to that later. Yes, we're going to break all of this down. And I wanted to share, you know, the first webisode series, The Accountants, was written by Paul Lieberstein and Mike Schurr. It was directed by Randall Einhorn. Subtle Sexuality was directed by Mindy Kaling. And it was written by our writer's assistants,
》。你仍然可以在 Peacock 和 NBC.com 上观看所有这些。两处都有。我也真的很喜欢《隔壁女孩》。它真的很洗脑。嗯哼。是的，我的意思是，我们待会儿会说到那个。是的，我们要把这一切都剖析一番。我想分享一下，你知道，第一部网络剧系列《会计师》是由保罗·李伯斯坦和迈克·舒尔编剧的。它由兰德尔·艾因霍恩导演。而《低调性感》是由敏迪·卡灵导演的。它由我们的编剧助理
Nate Fetterman and Jonathan Hughes. You guys might remember Nate Fetterman from Stress Relief. When we broke down that episode, he had the makeout scene with Cloris Leachman, and he shared his story with us. It's a great story. If you want to go back and listen to it, it's awesome. Well, we reached out to Nate again and he shared a bunch of stuff with us
内特·费特曼和乔纳森·休斯编剧。你们可能还记得《压力缓解》里的内特·费特曼。当我们剖析那一集时，他和克萝丽斯·利奇曼有了一场吻戏，他跟我们分享了他的故事。这是一个很棒的故事。如果你想回去听听，它太棒了。嗯，我们再次联系了内特，他跟我们分享了很多内容
that we'll be sprinkling in today as we discuss these webisodes. There is so much fun behind the scenes stuff about the making of this series as well. BJ Novak had this to say about Mindy being the director and I thought it perfectly sets up what we're about to talk about. BJ said,
，我们会在今天讨论这些网络剧时穿插其中。关于这个系列的制作，也有很多有趣的幕后花絮。B·J·诺瓦克对敏迪担任导演一事发表了这样的看法，我觉得这完美地铺垫了我们要谈论的内容。B·J 说：
She has such a distinct vision. She very much gravitates towards things that are fun and sparkly. And this is a very fun and sparkly webisode series. Oh, yes! Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, it'll be time for some subtle sexuality. I think Keanu has some subtle sexuality. You think?
她有一种非常独特的视野。她非常倾向于那些有趣且闪闪发光的事物。而这是一个非常有趣且闪闪发光的网络剧系列。哦，是的！那么，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？当我们回来时，将是“低调性感”的时间。我觉得基努也有点低调性感。你觉得呢？
This segment is brought to you by Macy's. Well it's the sweetest time of year. Valentine's Day is approaching and Macy's has the, it's the sweetest time of year. Valentine's Day is approaching, and Macy's has the best of the best gifts for your loved ones. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. The perfect Valentine's Day looks different for everyone. Some people go all out.
本环节由梅西百货为您倾情赞助。嗯，这是一年中最为甜蜜的时刻。情人节即将来临，梅西百货为您精心准备了，这是一年中最为甜蜜的时刻。情人节即将来临，梅西百货为你的挚爱准备了最好的礼物。这个情人节，让梅西百货成为你的送礼指南。完美的情情人节对每个人来说都不尽相同。有些人会大肆庆祝。
Some people keep it simple. Lady, if we had to plan the perfect Valentine's Day for everyone on the office. The characters on the office. Yes. What would it be? I was trying to think about Jam and Valentine's Day. And you know, I did a whole breakdown on how they do not have a good track record for Valentine's
有些人则保持低调。女士，如果我们得为办公室里的每个人策划一个完美的情情人节。办公室里的角色们。是的。那会是什么样？我在试着思考詹姆和情人节。你知道的，我做了一个全面的分析，关于他们在情人节
Day. Their Valentine's Day almost always stinks. So if I had to plan a good Valentine's Day, honestly, I think it would just be like, maybe they get to finally go have a nice dinner, maybe go to a Philly basketball game. I don't know. Maybe they could do like a brunch date and then go to some art museums. I guess it depends on who plans it. Exactly. I know what they don't want to do on Valentine's Day. They do not want to be in a throuple with Robert, California. No, they do not.
方面并没有什么好纪录。他们的情人节几乎总是很糟糕。所以如果我必须策划一个好的情人节，老实说，我觉得那可能就像是，也许他们终于可以去吃顿丰盛的晚餐，也许去看一场费城篮球队的比赛。我不知道。也许他们可以来个早午餐约会，然后去一些艺术博物馆。我想这取决于谁来策划。没错。我知道他们情人节绝对不想做什么。他们可不想和罗伯特·加州搞三人行。不，他们才不想呢。
No. Well, the one person we know who is going to have a great Valentine's Day is always Phyllis because Bob Vance goes all out. And let me tell you, he would go to Macy's because they have everything, perfume, chocolates, jewelry, handbags. He'd probably get her some silk nightie. Yeah, something for the boudoir. Yeah, of anyone on the show, we know Phyllis is having a good Valentine's Day.
不。嗯，我们知道唯一一个能过上一个棒极了的情人节的人总是菲利斯，因为鲍勃·万斯总是大手笔。而且我告诉你，他会去梅西百货，因为那里应有尽有：香水、巧克力、珠宝、手提包。他可能会给她买件丝绸睡衣。是的，给闺房准备的东西。是的，在剧中的所有人里，我们知道菲利斯的的情人节过得很美。
Yeah. Michael would probably want to be the center of attention. So he would like take his date to his improv show. Yes. That would be his gift to her. To make her watch him do improv. Yes. That was Cassie's idea.
是的。迈克尔可能会想成为众人瞩目的焦点。所以他会带他的约会对象去他的即兴喜剧演出。是的。这将是他送给她的礼物。让她看他表演即兴喜剧。是的。那是卡茜的主意。
I absolutely love that, Cassie. Well, Macy's really does fit so well into anyone's Valentine's Day plans. In fact, I have a pitch for people this Valentine's Day. If you haven't gotten them anything, you could make like a little coupon for like a shopping spree. Oh, that's fine. And then you just take them to Macy's and you can sit and watch them try stuff on or like smell the perfume or whatever it is but like a shopping spree date. Fashion show, fashion show, fashion show at lunch. Yes! You know we are huge supporters of Macy's all year long and they make shopping so simple for every occasion with their gift guides. We love their gift guides
我绝对爱死那个了，卡茜。嗯，梅西百货确实非常契合任何人的情人节计划。事实上，我今年情人节有个建议。如果你还没给他们买什么东西的话，你可以制作一个小优惠券，比如购物狂欢。哦，那太好了。然后你只要带他们去梅西百货，你就可以坐在那儿看着他们试穿东西，或者闻闻香水什么的，但就像是一场购物狂欢约会。时装秀，时装秀，午餐时的时装秀！是的！你知道我们一年到头都是梅西百货的坚定支持者，他们通过礼品指南让每个场合的购物都变得如此简单。我们爱死他们的礼品指南了
and hand-picked gifts for everyone on your list. It takes all the guessing work out of the process. This Valentine's Day, let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Shop in-store or online at macy's dot com slash gift guide. I was sick, but I am healing. Returning to W Network and StacTV. The West Side Ripper is back. If you're not killing these people, then who is? That's what I want to know. Starring Kaylee Cuoco and Chris Messina. The only investigating I'm doing these days is who shit their pants.
，还有为你的清单上的每个人精心挑选的礼物。它省去了过程中的所有猜测。这个情人节，让梅西百货成为你的送礼指南。在实体店购物，或登录 macy's dot com slash gift guide 在线购买。我生病了，但我正在康复。回归 W Network 和 StacTV。西区开膛手回来了。如果你不是在杀这些人，那是谁？这就是我想知道的。由凯莉·库柯和克里斯·梅西纳主演。我这些天唯一在调查的是谁拉裤子里了。
Killer messaged you yesterday? This is so dangerous. I got to get out of this. Based on a true story. New season Mondays at 9 Eastern and Pacific. Only on W. Stream on Stack TV. Ready to make your next big move? Rotman Executive Programs at the University of Toronto offers top tier professional development. Whether you're moving up in your current role or preparing for the next,
杀手昨天给你发信息了？这太危险了。我得离开这里。根据真实故事改编。新季每周一东部时间晚 9 点和太平洋时间播出。仅在 W。在 Stack TV 上播出。准备好迈出你的下一个重大职业步伐了吗？多伦多大学罗特曼管理学院高管培训项目提供顶尖的专业发展。无论你是想在现有职位上晋升还是为下一个职位做准备，
expand your business acumen, sharpen leadership skills, and gain cutting edge insights from world class Rotman faculty. Accelerate your career with Rotman executive programs. Visit www.uoft.me slash rotman 2025 to learn more. That's www.uoft.me slash rotman 2025. Hello, we are back and we're going to start breaking down this webisode. So Nate told us that when he and Jonathan were approached to write the next set of webisodes, Mindy pitched an idea that Kelly and Erin were creating a Twilight fan fiction movie. So Nate and Jonathan worked with her to develop that idea. They kind of landed on a structure where we would see the making of the movie.
扩展你的商业敏锐度，磨练领导技能，并从世界一流的罗特曼教员那里获得前沿见解。通过罗特曼高管培训项目加速你的职业生涯。访问 www.uoft.me slash rotman 2025 了解更多信息。即 www.uoft.me slash rotman 2025。哈啰，我们回来了，我们要开始剖析这部网络剧了。内特告诉我们，当他和乔纳森被接洽去编写下一批网络剧时，敏迪提出一个点子，即凯莉和艾琳在创作一部《暮光之城》同人小说电影。所以内特和乔纳森与她一起开发了这个点子。他们最终确定了一个结构，即我们将看到电影的制作过程。
And then the final webisode in the series would be Kelly and Erin's short film. Well, I guess the folks at NBCUniversal were worried about clearance issues. So, they had to go back to the drawing board. Nate and Jonathan brainstormed some other areas that had that same kind of structure. And they pitched the idea that Kelly that same kind of structure, and they pitched the idea that Kelly and Erin start a girl group and make their first music video. Well, Nate said Mindy loved this idea. Right?
然后该系列的最后一集将是凯利和艾琳的短片。好吧，我猜 NBCUniversal 的员工担心版权清算问题。所以，他们不得不重新回到图纸前重新规划。内特和乔纳森集思广益了一些其他具有相同结构的领域。他们提出了这样的点子：凯利，拥有相同的结构，并且他们提出了凯利
Fun and sparkly. Mm-hmm. And so did the execs at NBC, and so they were given the green light to write it. Well, on the official Subtle Sexuality website, they have a fun little synopsis of who the group is, and I thought I would read it. It says, there's nothing subtle about Subtle Sexuality. They're a girl group that features two diva-licious divas, the beautiful and mysterious Kelly Kapoor and the pretty Erin Hannon.
和艾琳组建一个女子组合并制作她们的第一支音乐录影带的点子。好吧，内特说敏迪非常喜欢这个点子。对吧？有趣且闪闪发光。嗯哼。NBC 的高管们也很喜欢，所以他们拿到了绿灯去编写它。好吧，在官方的“低调性感”网站上，他们对这个组合是谁有一个有趣的简短剧情简介，我想我把它读一下。上面写着，
These independent ladies can do it all, sing, dance, be fierce they're salacious, and work it all at the same time. Straight out of Scranton, PA, their new single is inspired by Beyonce, Katy Perry, Jay Hud, and all the Kardashians. Tear it open and you'll never be able to put it back in the box because subtle sexuality is more than just a pop group, it's a way of life. Hmm, I do want to tell you all that on the website, Kelly's name is the biggest, everyone else's is kind of small.
低调性感可一点都不低调。她们是一个女子组合，拥有两位巨星级的超级巨星，美丽而神秘的凯利·卡普尔和漂亮的艾琳·汉农。这些独立的女性无所不能：唱歌、跳舞、气场全开，她们既性感又魅惑，同时还能完美驾驭这一切。她们直接来自宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿，她们的新单曲灵感来自碧昂丝、凯蒂·佩里、詹妮弗·哈德森以及卡戴珊家族的所有人。一旦你打开它，你就再也无法把它塞回盒子里，因为低调性感不仅仅是一个流行乐队，它是一种生活方式。嗯，我确实想告诉大家，在网站上，凯利的名字是最大的，其他人的名字都挺小的。
Like the font? Yes. It's huge. And then it says at the bottom, featuring Nardog and Mr. Understood. Oh, these are their pop names. Mm-hmm. Got it. All right.
就像字体一样？是的。它巨大无比。然后它在底部写着，特邀纳多格和误解先生。哦，这些是他们的流行艺名。嗯哼。明白了。好的。
Well, we start with part one. It's titled Creative Differences. We find out that most of the office is away at a software training program. Mm-hmm. I guess this is how they explained why we're not all in the background. Right, and also why maybe they're shooting
好吧，我们从第一部分开始。它的标题是《创作分歧》。我们发现办公室的大部分人都不在，去参加软件培训项目了。嗯哼。我猜这就是他们解释为什么我们没有全部出现在背景中的原因。没错，这也解释了为什么他们可能在
at Dunder Mifflin, because no one's there, except for Oscar and Kevin. Yeah, they didn't need to learn the new software. They sent you, Angela, to represent. Accounting, clearly. Well, this is when we're going to find out that Kelly and Erin have decided to film their music video. We find out that the name of their band is Subtle Sexuality.
邓德米夫林拍摄，因为那里没有人，除了奥斯卡和凯文。是的，他们不需要学习新软件。他们派了你，安吉拉，去代表。显然是会计部。好吧，这就是我们将要发现凯利和艾琳决定拍摄她们的音乐录影带的时候。我们发现她们乐队的名字叫“低调性感”。
We go into the kitchen, and we see a shot of Kelly doing Ryan's makeup for the shoot. It's one of those classic moments where you only see Kelly and Ryan. Ryan's wearing a robe, and Kelly's putting on his eyeliner, and she's looking to camera and she's like, you know when you love a guy and he's giving you mixed signals but you know he really likes you and you're sleeping with him? And Ryan goes goes more eyeliner. And then Kelly goes I'll never tell you who the song is about this is a secret that I will take to my grave and Ryan goes it's about me and Kelly goes it is but I'll never say and then we reveal
我们走进厨房，看到一个镜头是凯利正在为瑞安上妆以准备拍摄。那是那种经典的时刻，你只能看到凯利和瑞安。瑞安穿着浴袍，凯利正在给他画眼线，她看着镜头说，你知道当你爱上一个家伙，而他给你发出矛盾的信号，但你知道他是真的很喜欢你，而且你正在跟他睡觉？然后瑞安说：眼线再浓点。接着凯利说，我永远不会告诉你这首歌是写给谁的，这是一个我要带进棺材的秘密，然后瑞安说，是写给我的，凯利说，是的，但我绝不说，然后我们揭晓
Oscar has been sitting there the whole time just trying to eat a sandwich and he says do you guys need to do this here this This is a public area. And Kelly's like, it's our office too, Oscar. And then lady, I just love this. She says to Ryan, I think it's too much rouge. And he goes, no, it's not going to read on camera. And she's like, how do you know what's going to read on camera? And he goes, I lived in New York for 11 months.
奥斯卡一直坐在那里，只是想吃个三明治，他说，你们必须在这里做这个吗？这是一个公共区域。凯利说，这也是我们的办公室，奥斯卡。然后女士，我太喜欢这个了。她对瑞安说，我觉得腮红太多了。然后他说，不，这在镜头前显现不出来。然后她说，你怎么知道什么在镜头前显现得出来？然后他说，我在纽约住了 11 个月。
Living in New York for 11 months tells you everything. I guess about what reads on camera. Cracked me up. Then Ryan has a super douchey talking head. Oh yeah. He's explaining why he's participating in the music video and he's like, what can I say? I love music.
在纽约住 11 个月能告诉你一切。我想是关于什么在镜头前显现得出来。把我逗笑了。然后瑞安有一个超级混蛋式的单人访谈。哦，是的。他解释他为什么要参与这个音乐录影带，他说，我能说什么呢？我热爱音乐。
And then he goes on to say, in fact, if he had to choose a life without sex or a life without music, he to choose a life without sex or a life without music he would choose a life without sex. I don't believe him. Well he says girls will find other ways to take care of me. I still don't believe him. All right now we're going to move to the parking lot and we're setting up our first shot of the music video. Yeah Kelly is dressed as a bride but she also was like smoking a cigarette like she's a tough girl. This whole look reminded me very much of early Madonna, like, like a virgin, that wedding
然后他接着说，事实上，如果他必须在没有性的生活和没有音乐的生活之间做出选择，他选择没有性的生活，或是没有音乐的生活，他会选择没有性的生活。我不相信他。好吧，他说女孩们会找到其他方式来照顾我。我还是不相信他。好了，现在我们要移动到停车场，正在为音乐录影带拍摄第一个镜头。是的，凯莉打扮成一个新娘，但她也像个抽烟的硬汉一样叼着烟。整个造型让我想起了早期的麦当娜，就像《像处女那样》那种婚礼婚纱造型。
dress look. Yep. Erin is dressed as a minister and she's also working the camera. Yes. Ryan comes out, he's very impatient. He's like, my blood sugar is low. When are we getting to me? Kelly is trying to light a cigarette, and she yells at him and goes, you should have finished the soy yogurt I gave you. The level of stress while they're filming was cracking me up.
没错。艾琳打扮成牧师，她还在操作摄像机。是的。瑞安走出来，他非常不耐烦。他说，我的血糖很低。我们什么时候拍到我？凯莉正试图点烟，她冲他大喊，你本该吃完我给你的豆奶酸奶的。他们在拍摄时的紧张程度让我笑死。
I also want to point out that Kelly has a splint on her finger. It's on her left pointer finger. This will pay off later. Yes. Also, lady, when I was watching Mindy try to smoke this cigarette in this scene, it was making me laugh. Did you ever have to smoke for a role? Did you ever have to smoke a cigarette for any of your characters? No, I have not. And I am telling you right now, I would just completely botch it. I don't know that I wouldn't quite know how to hold it or light it. I've never smoked.
我还想指出，凯莉的指头上戴着夹板。戴在她的左手食指上。这个细节后面会呼应。是的。还有，女士，当我看着敏迪在这个场景里试图抽这根烟时，我真的觉得很好笑。你以前演戏时抽过烟吗？你为你的任何角色抽过烟吗？不，我没有。我向你保证，我绝对会把这事搞砸。我不知道，我可能根本不知道该怎么拿它或者怎么点燃它。我从来没抽过烟。
So I wouldn't know what to do with it. I had to smoke in a movie. I had to smoke a lot in this movie called A Little Help. And I loved it was just a great part. It's a really great movie. And I was so afraid that I was gonna look like a nonsmoker, which is what I am for all the things you're saying. I mean, I'm sure a real smoker,
所以我不知道该拿它怎么办。我曾在一部电影里抽过烟。我必须在一部叫《稍微帮个忙》的电影里抽很多烟。我挺喜欢那部分的，这是个很棒的角色。这真的是一部很棒的电影。我当时非常担心自己看起来会像个不会抽烟的人，正如我刚才说的各种原因。我的意思是，我确信真正的抽烟者，
they can probably tell right away. Yeah, well, I mean, I started smoking as soon as I got the part. I just started slowly smoking. Like what? Like those? I couldn't do the fakies. I couldn't do the fakie clove cigarettes so that I had I had like a four month period of my life where I smoked cigarettes. That's insane, lady. I know insane. Yeah.
他们可能一眼就能看出来。好吧，我的意思是，我一拿到这个角色就开始抽烟了。我开始慢慢抽烟。就像什么？就像那些？我搞不定那些假烟。我搞不定那些假的丁香烟，所以我人生中有大约四个月的时间抽过香烟。这太疯狂了，女士。我知道这很疯狂。是的。
Was it gross? Do you want the truth? Or do you want me to say what I should say? Cassie, Cassie, this is your year. I think I know what you wanna say. There was a lot about it that I liked. Okay, well, you must- Don't smoke everybody.
这很恶心吗？你想听实话？还是想让我说我该说的话？凯茜，凯茜，这是属于你的一年。我想我知道你想说什么。这里面有很多我喜欢的地方。好吧，你一定——大家千万别抽烟。
There was a lot about it that messed with my sinuses. And I was like, by the end of the four months, I was like, this is, I can't do this and I have to quit. And I did. And I'm glad I did. But you smoked for the movie. And I smoked not just on camera. I mean, I had to smoke in my life. I would, you know, practice smoking while I drove my car because I had a scene where I had to smoke in my life. I would, you know, practice smoking while I drove my car because I had a scene where I had to smoke in the car, and then I had a scene where I was walking down the street
里面有很多东西把我的鼻窦弄得很遭。到了四个月结束的时候，我在想，这不行，我做不到，我必须戒掉。我真的戒了。我很高兴我戒了。但你为了电影而抽烟。而且我不仅在镜头前抽。我的意思是，我在日常生活中也得抽。我会，你知道的，开着车练习抽烟，因为我有一个场景必须在车里抽烟，然后我还有一个场景是走在街上
talking to someone, so I would practice that. I had to practice lighting cigarettes because I wanted to get all the business correct. This is very good actor-Method-y stuff you did. Yeah. Yeah. But, you know, I really enjoyed having a cup of coffee and a piece of chocolate cake and a cigarette. I'm not, I mean, I'm so sorry. It sounds so, I don't know, it sounds so gross to me.
跟别人说话，所以我要练习这个。我必须练习点烟，因为我想把所有的动作都做得准确。这是非常专业的演员方法派表演啊。对。对。但是，你知道的，我真的很享受喝一杯咖啡、吃一块巧克力蛋糕再抽根烟。我不是说，天哪，我很抱歉。听起来，我不知道，听起来太恶心了。
It was so good. And I mean, I feel so bad saying this, children don't smoke. But yeah, it was something about it. And it was, you know, it was relaxing all the things why people get addicted to it. I get it. Right, right. I get it. But I stopped because it also would make me wake up and I would blow my nose and it would be like brown and then I would have a sore throat and I would cough. I mean it had a horrible, in a short period of time, had horrible effects on my health. Well, I think this is a horrible transition, but Kelly did not do any of that research.
真的太棒了。而且我是说，说这话我感到很内疚，孩子们千万别抽烟。但是，是的，它有一种特别的感觉。而且，你知道的，它很放松，也就是人们会对它上瘾的各种原因。我懂。对，对。我懂。但我停下来是因为它还会让我醒来时擤出棕色的鼻涕，然后我还会喉咙痛、咳嗽。我的意思是，它在短时间内对我的健康产生了可怕的影响。好吧，我觉得这是一个糟糕的转场，但凯莉根本没有做任何这样的研究。
She's doing a horrible job lighting her cigarette, and then she starts coughing and choking, and then she says, excuse me, I think I have to go vomit. That's how this webisode ends. The next webisode in this series is called The Replacement. Mmm. Yeah. Who's getting replaced?
她点烟的动作烂透了，然后她开始咳嗽、作呕，接着她说，不好意思，我想我要去吐了。这个网络剧集就是这样结束的。这个系列的下一集叫做《替补》。嗯。对。谁要被替换了？
Erin has a talking head. She says, you know what? The shoot was going really well until Kelly and Ryan got in a fight. Then the poop hit the fan. Yeah. Erin is trying to calm Kelly down when Kevin approaches, and he says, you know what? Do you need someone to step in for Ryan? Cause I'll step in, I'll do it.
艾琳有一段面对镜头的独白。她说，你知道吗？拍摄进展得很顺利，直到凯莉和瑞安打了一架。然后事情就彻底搞砸了。是的。艾琳正试图安抚凯莉，这时凯文走过来，他说，你知道吗？你需要有人顶替瑞安吗？因为我会顶替，我来干。
And Kelly clearly does not want him to step in for Ryan. So she makes him the cameraman and he's really happy about that. He's excited. Except he has jelly on his hands and they're like, you got to wipe that jelly off your hands before you hold the camera. So Kevin just wipes it on the file cabinet. So gross. Way to go, Kevin.
而凯莉显然不想让他顶替瑞安。于是她让他当摄影师，他对此非常高兴。他很兴奋。除了他手上沾了果冻，他们对他说，你得把手上的果冻擦掉才能拿摄像机。于是凯文直接把它擦在文件柜上。太恶心了。干得好，凯文。
Kelly still has a splint on her finger here, still on her left hand, still on her pointer finger. While this conversation is going on, Andy is singing by the vending machines. He is singing to the tune of Beethoven's Fifth Symphony. Vending machine, vending machine, I want to treat something to eat. It's really funny. And of course, they overhear him singing and they're like, huh, this cuts to an
凯莉这里的指头上仍然戴着夹板，依然在她的左手上，依然在她的食指上。正当这场对话进行时，安迪在自动售货机旁唱歌。他唱的是贝多芬第五交响曲的调子。自动售货机，自动售货机，我想吃点好吃的。这真的太搞笑了。当然，他们无意中听到他唱歌，心想，哈，镜头切到了
Andy talking head. And I absolutely loved it. He describes how he auditions for them. And I think you need to hear it. So they asked me to audition for subtle sexuality. So I gave them a little And I think you need to hear it. So they asked me to audition for subtle sexuality. So I gave them a little doodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodledoodled I'm like, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, I was in a band and we used to mess with each other on stage like this all the time. And one of my friends who I was performing with that night was like, well, of course, she's an amazing beatboxer. And then the whole crowd looks at you and you're like, damn you.
Andy的单人访谈镜头。我绝对太喜欢了。他讲述了自己是如何去试镜的。我觉得你们必须听听。所以他们让我为“微妙性感”试镜。所以我给了他们一点……我觉得你们必须听听。所以他们让我为“微妙性感”试镜。所以我给了他们一点……哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒……我当时就想，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿……我以前在一个乐队里，我们在舞台上经常这样互相恶搞。那天晚上跟我一起演出的一个朋友就说，哦，当然啦，她是个了不起的B-box口技高手。然后全场观众都看着你，你就会想，该死。
So I think I did something like this. Pretty good, it's better than me. I don't know, I just made it up on the spot you guys, it's not good. That was good. Cassie, can you beatbox? Okay. It's a really cool thing that people can do. I actually find it really fascinating. No, I agree and I was wondering if Ed like just already kind of had that skill or if he read the script
所以我想我大概做了这样的动作。挺好的，比我强。我不知道，我当时就即兴发挥的嘛，大家伙，其实不太好。刚才那个挺好的。卡西，你会B-box吗？好吧。这是大家都能做到的一件非常酷的事。我其实觉得这真的太迷人了。不，我同意，而且我当时就在想，艾德是本来就会这手绝活，还是说他读了剧本
and was like, oh boy, kind of like you with the improv. Because that happens. Like sometimes they'll write something for you to do and you're like, wait, what? Wait, wait, what? Here we go. Well, Kelly is now going over the choreography with Andy and Erin for the video. She says one and two and cross and cross down, sexy, sexy, sexy. There is behind the scenes footage of this,
然后心想，哦天哪，就有点像你对即兴表演的那种反应。因为确实会这样。有时候他们会写一些东西让你去演，然后你就会想，等等，什么？等等，等等，什么？我们这就来。好了，凯莉现在正在和安迪还有艾琳一起过视频的舞蹈动作。她说：一，二，交叉，再交叉，往下，性感，性感，性感。幕后有这方面的花絮，
of them practicing the dances, and Mindy and Ellie talking about who's good at what dance move. It's so cute, this behind the scenes footage. I wanna include part of it in our stories. Well, I remember when they were getting ready to shoot this, that they were singing the songs on set between scenes. They were actually working on this stuff.
也就是他们练习舞蹈的片段，明迪和艾莉在讨论谁擅长哪个舞蹈动作。这些幕后花絮太可爱了。我想把其中的一部分剪到我们的动态里。好吧，我记得当他们准备拍摄这个的时候，他们在片场排练间隙一直在唱这些歌。他们其实一直在琢磨这些东西。
It was really fun. We were like, what are you guys doing? What are you guys doing? And then Ellie said in an interview that she was like listening to it, like at the gym, like on her run, like just learning the song. Yeah, cause they had to like lip sync it.
真的特别好玩。我们当时就想，你们在干嘛呢？你们在干嘛呢？然后艾莉在一次采访中说，她一直在听这首歌，比如在健身房的时候，跑步的时候，就一直在学这首歌。对，因为他们必须得假唱。
Yeah. Well, listen, Ryan is going to interrupt and he's finding out that he's being replaced. He is not happy about it. He's like, this guy, you're replacing me with this guy? And he's like, you know what, we've met before. And then Kelly has a line. It really cracks me up.
对。好吧，听着，瑞恩要来打断了，他发现自己被取代了。他非常不高兴。他大概是说，这家伙，你用这家伙来代替我？然后他说，你知道吗，我们以前见过。接着凯莉有句台词。真的把我逗笑了。
She goes, this video is bigger than you or me. Yeah. Doesn't stop Ryan though. He's going to grab her in an embrace. They're going to make out. And then Ryan says to her, I'll see you at five and Kelly kind of wistfully watches him leave and Andy's like, but can I still be in the video? All right, so now it is time. Part three of this web series is the music video. It is the music video
她说，这个视频比你我都要宏大。没错。不过这也阻止不了瑞恩。他一把将她搂进怀里。他们俩亲热起来。然后瑞恩对她说，我五点见你，凯莉则带着几分留恋的目光看着他离开，安迪在一旁说，那我还能不能出现在视频里？好啦，现在时候到了。这个网络剧集的第三部分就是音乐录影带。这就是音乐录影带
for Subtle Sexuality's song, Male Prima Donna. So good. Eve Nelson wrote the music for this song. She was our go-to music person. She is an Emmy award winning composer. She also wrote the original music for the song in Scott's Tots and all of the music for Threat Level Midnight. The song is just so catchy.
也就是“微妙性感”乐队的歌曲《男名伶》。太棒了。伊芙·纳尔逊为这首歌谱了曲。她是我们御用的音乐人。她是一位艾美奖获奖作曲家。她还为《斯科特的幼儿们》中的歌曲创作了原创音乐，并包揽了《最高机密》的所有音乐。这首歌实在是太洗脑了。
Vulture interviewed Mindy and they described the video like this. They channeled the look, sound and aesthetic of Lady Gaga's 2008 Just Dance and Kesha's 2010 song TikTok. I went back and watched both of those music videos. And did you see the influence? Yes, absolutely. We're not going to play the full song for you guys, but you've got to hear the chorus of Male Primad donna here it is Prima Donna. Prima Donna. Oh!
Vulture网站采访了明迪，他们是这样形容这个MV的：他们复刻了Lady Gaga 2008年单曲《Just Dance》以及凯莎2010年歌曲《TikTok》的造型、曲风和美学。我回去把这两支MV都看了一遍。你们看出那种影响了吗？对，完全看出来了。我们就不给大家播完整版的歌了，但你们一定要听听《男名伶》的副歌，就是这个：名伶。名伶。哦！
Lady, I had this song stuck in my head for days. Days. I mean, I'm going to sing it probably today. In the behind the scenes footage, there is a part where Ellie's in front of a microphone and Mindy's watching her and she's just going, oh! Oh! Oh!
天哪，这首歌在我脑子里盘旋了好几天。好几天。我是说，我今天可能还得唱呢。在幕后花絮里，有一个片段是艾莉站在话筒前，明迪看着她，她嘴里一直发出：哦！哦！哦！
Is that from when they were recording the song? Yes. And you can see Eve there, too. Listen, not only is this song amazing, I can't get enough of the costumes in this music video. They're very interesting and also very random. Very random. Also in the behind the scenes video,
那是他们录歌时候的画面吗？对。你还能在那儿看到伊芙。听着，这首歌不仅绝了，我对这个MV里的服装更是百看不厌。它们非常有趣，而且也十分随性。极其随性。同样在幕后花絮视频里，
you see them in the costume department, and they're clearly trying on different looks. I had to do a costume breakdown. I expected it. Okay. Well, their first look, I'm gonna start with Kelly. She's wearing gold spandex leggings with a sort of like a cheetah print leotard
你能看到他们在服装部，他们显然在试穿各种不同的造型。我得做一份服装拆解。我料到了。好吧。他们的第一个造型，我先从凯莉开始说起。她穿着金色弹力紧身打底裤，搭配一件类似于猎豹印花的连体衣
and a big black chunky belt with long dark purple gloves up to her elbows and tall black boots. This is what you thought I was gonna wear in today. I thought you might wear gold. A version of this. I thought you might wear gold leggings or something. You said, look, I have an outfit.
还有一条又粗又大的黑色腰带，戴着长到手肘的深紫色长手套，脚踩高筒黑色靴子。这就是你以为我今天会穿的行头。我以为你可能会穿金色。类似这样的版本。我以为你可能会穿金色打底裤什么的。你说过，看，我有一套衣服。
Have you ever met me before? Lady. Gold leggings. Honey, not only have I met you and been your friend for years, but let's just talk about what you wore to Halloween that year, where you dressed like someone from the 1980s. I know I wore a neon track suit because I don't want anything you know tight.
你以前真的认识我吗？天哪。金色打底裤。亲爱的，我不仅认识你、当了你多年朋友，咱们还得聊聊你当年万圣节穿的那身衣服，你当时打扮得像个上世纪80年代的人。我知道我穿了一身霓虹运动服，因为我什么紧身的都不想要。
Well you might wear some kind of gold lame I thought I thought you might wear something inspired. Cheetah print. Fair enough fair enough. Okay I'm not done with Kelly's first look. No go. She also has sort of like a blue lightning bolt thing on her cheek. This is very Lady Gaga in her Just Dance video. Okay. Okay. Erin is wearing the same gold spandex leggings and it looks like she has a black leotard
好吧，你可能会穿某种金银丝面料的衣服……我以为我以为你可能会穿点有设计感的。猎豹印花。好吧，好吧。行吧，凯莉的第一个造型还没完呢。接着说。她的脸颊上还有一个类似于蓝色闪电形状的贴纸。这非常有Lady Gaga在《Just Dance》MV里的风格。好吧。好吧。艾琳穿着同款金色弹力紧身打底裤，看起来她穿了一件黑色连体衣，
but then over the black leotard they put this gold sparkly tank top blouse with also a big black chunky belt. She has black gloves but they only go just a little bit past her wrist. And she also has the tall black boots. Then they have a second look, which we already talked about. It's Kelly as the bride and Erin as a priest.
但在黑色连体衣外面，她们套上了一件金色亮片背心上衣，同样系着一条又粗又大的黑色腰带。她戴着黑色手套，但只稍微过了一点手腕。她也踩着高筒黑色靴子。然后她们还有第二个造型，我们之前已经讨论过了。就是凯莉扮演新娘，艾琳扮演牧师。
Then they have a third look. I guess we're calling it sexy pirate. Yes, this was where they went in a new direction. Mm-hmm. They're dressed as like, yeah. Yeah. Sexy pirates. Yeah, yeah. That's what we're calling it. Kelly has a bedazzled silver and diamond patch over one eye. She has a silver sparkly knit hat. Erin has a full stuffed parrot on her shoulder with a black beret and then they both have these versions of like kind of a black and white outfit look, like with black and white stripes.
接下来是第三个造型。我猜我们称之为性感海盗。是的，这是她们尝试全新风格的方向。嗯哼。她们打扮得就像，对。对。性感海盗。对，对。我们就是这么叫的。凯莉的一只眼睛上戴着一个镶满水钻和钻石的银色眼罩。她戴着一顶银色亮片针织帽。艾琳的肩膀上站着一只塞满填充物的完整鹦鹉玩偶，头上戴着一顶黑色贝雷帽，然后她们俩都穿着这种黑白两色风格的服装，带有黑白相间的条纹。
That's their third book. But then there's also a few shots of them as they're lip syncing and dancing to this song where they're just in their work clothes as well. Yeah, it like kind of cuts back to their normal day wear. Mm-hmm. There is a portion of the music video that finally explains the splint on Kelly's finger. Erin has a lyric that explains it. I thought we should listen.
那是她们的第三个造型。但其中也穿插了一些镜头，是她们跟着这首歌对口型和跳舞，当时她们身上穿的其实就是她们的工作服。对，画面会切换回她们平时的日常着装。嗯哼。MV里有一部分内容终于解释了凯莉手指上的夹板是怎么回事。艾琳有句歌词解释了这一点。我觉得我们应该听听。
You slammed her finger in the car door. Didn't say you're sorry. Love is long. She got stitches. It really hurt. That's her blood on your polo shirt. Yeah. She got stitches. It really hurt. That's her blood on your polo shirt. Yeah. She got stitches, it really hurt.
你把她的手指夹在了车门里。连句对不起都没说。爱很漫长。她缝了针。真的很痛。那是留在你Polo衫上的血迹。对。她缝了针。真的很痛。那是留在你Polo衫上的血迹。对。她缝了针，真的很痛。
I love it. What's interesting is that at one point there's a shot of Kelly and the splint is on her ring finger. No, not her pointer finger. It traveled. Yeah, not sure which finger was injured. Well now Andy is gonna come in
我太喜欢了。有趣的是，在某个画面中，凯莉手上的夹板戴在她的无名指上。不，不是她的食指。它移位了。对，不确定到底是哪根手指受伤了。好吧，现在安迪要登场了
and he's got a whole interesting look as well. Oh yes, I did a breakdown of Andy's outfit. Okay. Andy, clearly in the story of making this video, didn't have a lot of time to put a costume together. So what he's done is he's kind of transformed his work outfit into a costume. So he's wearing his t-shirt and he's wearing his same suit jacket, but he's ripped the arms off and then he's wearing his tie and he's tied his long sleeve shirt around his waist. Yeah, his button down is now like around his waist.
而且他的整体造型也非常奇特。哦，对，我把安迪的衣服做了一番拆解。好吧。安迪在这个视频的故事设定里，显然没有太多时间去准备一套戏服。所以他做的事情是，把他的工作服改造了一下变成了一套戏服。所以他穿着T恤，穿着同一件西装外套，但他把袖子给撕掉了，然后他系着领带，把长袖衬衫系在腰间。对，他的系扣衬衫现在绑在腰上了。
Yeah, so it's kind of flowing. He has also just cut off the bottom of his pants. Why? So it's a it's an interesting look. Andy's portion of the song is pretty fabulous. I thought maybe we should hear it. Oh yeah. girl, while when you flash that sexy smile because before she met you things were going okay
对，所以看起来飘逸的。他还把裤腿剪短了一截。为什么？所以这算是一个挺有趣的造型。安迪在歌里的部分相当精彩。我觉得也许我们该听听。哦，对。女孩，当你绽放那个性感的微笑时，因为在你遇到她之前，一切都还算顺利
so go away or stay at the end there andy's harmonizing with himself yeah and they do this special effect where there's like three andys in one shot yeah he's like on either side of himself like bookends and then he's got also a pose in the middle. It's pretty special. It's great. So now Ryan comes in and his outfit is pretty incredible. Angela, do you have a breakdown of this one? Oh I do. So Ryan, first of all, you know his character is Mr. Understood. Yeah. He is wearing a white top hat, a white suit, with a pink handkerchief in his lapel pocket,
所以走开或者留下……在歌曲的结尾处，安迪在进行自我和声。对，他们做了一个特效，画面里出现了三个安迪。对，他就好像在自己的两侧各有一个分身，就像书挡一样，然后他在中间还有一个摆造型的镜头。挺特别的。太棒了。好了，现在瑞恩登场了，他的行头相当惊艳。安吉拉，你对这个造型有什么拆解吗？哦，我有。所以，瑞恩，首先呢，你知道他的角色名字叫“误解先生”。对。他戴着一顶白色礼帽，穿着白色西装，翻领口袋里插着一张粉色手帕，
with black and white checkered socks, with white dress shoes, a long gold necklace with some type of gold medallion, and a gold flashy watch. But in the behind the scenes bonus footage, BJ and Mindy talk about his costume. And here's what they said. Kelly gets to kind of erupt in this webisode series but also Mindy Kaling
脚上穿着黑白相间的格子袜，踩着白色正装皮鞋，脖子上戴着一条长长的金项链，上面挂着某种金色奖牌，手上戴着一块耀眼的金表。但在幕后花絮里，BJ和明迪谈到了他的戏服。以下是他们的原话：凯莉在这个网络剧集里得以爆发，但明迪·卡林
does too. She's directing these. She's in charge of my hair, she's in charge of my makeup, she's in charge of my wardrobe. It's sort of like Adam Levine meets boys to men type of thing. But he's gonna be wearing white shoes. I want her to wear a top hat and a cane. So she's handling the power very well. So she's handling the power very well. Cracked me up. You know what I love about this is that Mindy had a real vision. I mean, you can hear the detail in and the research that she put into this look and this music video and how it was gonna look. I mean, it's really phenomenal. It's really well directed.
也是如此。她在指导这些。她负责我的发型，她负责我的妆容，她负责我的服装。这有点像是“亚当·莱文遇上大人小孩双周组”那种感觉。但他会穿白色鞋子。我希望她戴着礼帽并拿着一根手杖。所以她把控权力把控得非常好。所以她把控权力把控得非常好。把我逗乐了。你知道我最喜欢这一点的是什么吗，那就是明迪有着真正的愿景。我是说，你能从这身造型、这个MV以及它最终呈现的效果中，听到她投入的细节和研究。我是说，这真的是太惊艳了。导演水平真的非常高。
Yeah. Well, I also thought we needed to hear Ryan's rap because it's so great. Yeah. So here is Mr. Understood. Call me Mr. Understood, cause no one understands me. But when I spit rhymes rhymes everybody buys my CD
对。好吧，我还觉得我们得听听瑞恩的饶唱，因为实在太棒了。对。所以，这位就是误解先生。叫我误解先生，因为没有人理解我。但当我即兴说唱时，每个人都会买我的CD
You get out of the car so slow. How was I supposed to know you keep saying stuff behind my back? How come I got the number one track? I'm the OG prima donna my rhymes bite like piranha Hotter than a sauna straight out of Lackawanna Yeah, Lackawanna. Yeah. Lackawanna. Also, BJ's face as Ryan, or Mr. Understood, whatever we're calling him, when he goes piranha, he's so into it.
你下车慢吞吞。我怎么会知道你一直在背后说我坏话？为什么我能拿到冠军单曲？我是初代名伶，我的说唱像食人鱼一样咬人，比桑拿房还热，直接来自拉克瓦纳，对，拉克瓦纳。对，拉克瓦纳。还有，当BJ扮演瑞恩，或者说误解先生，不管我们怎么叫他，当他唱到“食人鱼”时，他那个表情简直太投入了。
It's really pretty fabulous. The whole thing is pretty fabulous. And that's it. That's the end of this webisode, Subtle Sexuality. We're gonna take a break, but when we come back, we are gonna talk about Subtle Sexuality's follow-up music video, The Girl Next Door, and their making of documentary.
真的相当精彩。整首歌都相当精彩。好了，就这样。这就是网络短剧《微妙性感》的结尾。我们要休息一下，但等我们回来后，我们将讨论《微妙性感》的后续MV《隔壁女孩》，以及他们的幕后纪录片。
Which was narrated by Kevin Malone. Yes. ["The Girl Next Door"] Kevin Malone. Yes. Hello, dearest listener. In the thick of the winter season, you may be in need of some joie de vivre. Well look no further, honey, because Sunwing's Best Value Vacays has your budget-friendly escapes all the way to five-star luxury.
由凯文·马龙担任旁白。是的。["隔壁女孩"] 凯文·马龙。是的。你好，最亲爱的听众朋友。在这个严冬时节，你可能需要一些生活的快乐。别再找了，亲爱的，因为“太阳之翼最佳超值假期”为你提供从预算友好型一直到五星级奢华的全方位度假选择。
Yes, you heard correctly, budget and luxury all in one place. So instead of ice scraping and teeth chattering, choose coconut sipping and pole splashing. Oh, and book by February 16th with your local travel advisor or as. TD Direct Investing offers live support. So whether you're a newbie or a seasoned pro, you can make your investing steps count. And whether you're a newbie or a seasoned pro, you can make your investing steps count.
是的，你没听错，预算和奢华完美结合。所以，与其在室外铲冰、冻得直打哆嗦，不如选择啜饮椰子、在泳池里嬉戏。哦，请在2月16日之前通过当地的旅游顾问预订，或者……TD直接投资公司提供实时支持。所以无论你是新手还是经验丰富的老手，你都可以让你的投资举措发挥价值。无论你是新手还是经验丰富的老手，你都可以让你的投资举措发挥价值。
And if you're like me and think a TFSA stands for Total Fund Savings Adventure, maybe reach out to TD Direct Investing. Okay, we are back. Like we said before, this webisode series was so popular they produced two supplemental assets, if you will. Yes, the first supplemental video they released was a making of like a faux documentary of the band called Part-Time Band Full-Time Legend.
如果你像我一样，以为TFSA代表的是“全额基金储蓄冒险”，也许可以联系一下TD直接投资公司。好了，我们回来了。就像我们之前所说的，这个网络剧集系列实在是太火了，以至于他们又制作了两个补充内容，如果你愿意这么称呼的话。是的，他们发布的第一个补充视频是一部名为《兼职乐队，全职传奇》的伪纪录片式的幕后制作特辑。
It's the story of subtle sexuality as told by Kevin Malone. It's a very dramatic introduction. I thought we could hear it. This, my friends, is the powerful story of subtle sexuality. Part-time band, full-time legend. Remember 2009? Music was headed in a wild new direction back then. Nobody thought the boundaries could be pushed any further. Yeah, pushed any further. There's a chiron on the screen that says Kevin Malone, Scranton music critic. Yes, there's going to be a series of talking heads and everyone will have a title. Yes. Kelly's talking head, she's titled as lead singer. And she's going to explain, they were just kids, you know, they didn't care what they were singing. They just wanted to be original. Erin also has a talking head. Her title is other band member.
这是由凯文·马龙讲述的关于“微妙性感”的故事。这是一个非常戏剧性的开场。我觉得我们可以听听。这个，我的朋友们，就是关于“微妙性感”的传奇故事。兼职乐队，全职传奇。还记得2009年吗？那时的音乐正朝着一个疯狂的新方向发展。当时没有人认为边界还能被进一步推向极限。是的，被进一步推向极限。屏幕上出现了一个字幕条，上面写着：凯文·马龙，斯克兰顿音乐评论家。是的，接下来会有一系列的单人访谈，每个人都会有一个头衔。是的。凯莉的单人访谈，她的头衔是主唱。她将解释说，他们当时只是孩子，你知道的，他们根本不在乎自己在唱什么。他们只想做到原创。艾琳也有一个单人访谈。她的头衔是乐队其他成员。
And she says the best part was when they sang. Yeah. And then Andy has his talking head. His title is The Nard Dog. He's going over like, what does he love about subtle sexuality? And he just sort of says it's like an opportunity for him to express his musicianship and his sexuality all at once. Yeah. Yeah. He says he's cursed with overt sexuality. Yeah. I do want to point out during all of these interviews the setting is hilarious. Yes. Like Mindy thought of everything. So they are sitting in this room. There are candles on these tall pedestals and then the backdrop behind them is all this vibrant colors.
她说最棒的部分就是他们唱歌的时候。对。然后是安迪的单人访谈。他的头衔是“纳德狗”。他谈到了他究竟有多么热爱“微妙性感”，然后他大概是说，这对他来说就像是一个能同时表达他的音乐才华和性感的契机。对。对。他说他自带一种过度的性感。对。我必须指出，在所有这些采访中，背景布置简直太搞笑了。对。就像明迪考虑到了方方面面。所以他们坐在这样一个房间里。高高的底座上摆着蜡烛，然后他们身后的背景是各种鲜艳的色彩。
It looks like a bunch of like fans that you flip open, you know? But the colors are like purple and maroons. It kind of reminded me of like the talking heads that you see during like a bachelor or bachelorette show. Exactly. Like a reality show. Where they go to talk about if they got the rose or not and they're surrounded by candles and some backdrop. Yeah. Mindy thought of everything. So the next part of this documentary is gonna reveal, it's showing us their popularity. And so Kelly and Erin are in the conference room.
看起来就像是一把把被你哗啦一下展开的扇子，你知道吗？但颜色都是紫色和栗色那种。这让我有点想起你在看像《单身汉》或《单身女郎》这种节目时看到的单人访谈背景。没错。就像真人秀节目那样。他们去那里谈论自己有没有拿到玫瑰，周围环绕着蜡烛和某种背景。对。明迪考虑到了所有细节。所以这部纪录片的下一部分将要揭晓，它向我们展示了他们的受欢迎程度。所以凯莉和艾琳在会议室里。
They've got a table full of merch. There's a line out the door of people who want their autograph. Yeah. Lady, did you see who was first in line? Tom Melby. Tom Melby. Tom Melby. I know.
她们面前的桌子上摆满了周边商品。门外排起了长队，都是想要她们签名的人。对。天哪，你看到排在第一位的是谁了吗？汤姆·梅尔比。汤姆·梅尔比。汤姆·梅尔比。我懂。
We loved him. He was like our, what would you call him? He was like our everything man. He was like our handyman. Our superintendent, if you will, of the property. And his house was right behind our studio. Yeah. He was the person who would go in and water the plants
我们太爱他了。他就像我们的……你该怎么称呼他？他就像我们的万能先生。他就像我们的杂务工。如果你愿意的话，就是这处房产的物业管理员。他的房子就在我们工作室的后面。对。他就是那个会进去浇花的人
when we were all on vacation. I know. I ran into him recently. We were out at a farmer's market, and he was there. He was sitting, and he was having a margarita. Really? Yeah. And I said, Tom Melby?
当我们所有人都在度假的时候。我知道。我最近偶遇了他。我们当时去了一个农贸市场，他在那里。他坐在那儿，正在喝玛格丽特酒。真的吗？对。然后我说，汤姆·梅尔比？
And he couldn't believe it. And we got to chatting. He was so sweet. He just said how much he loved our book. and he just is a dear, dear person. Yeah, he is the kindest. I know I've talked about it before, but he would always let me take Isabel to his backyard, had a swing when she would come visit.
他简直不敢相信。然后我们聊了起来。他太温柔了。他只是说他有多么喜欢我们的书，他真的是一个非常非常亲切的人。对，他是最善良的人。我知道我以前说过，但每当伊莎贝尔来探访时，他总是让我带她去他的后院，那里有一个秋千。
He's the sweetest. I just love that he's in this webisode. Me too. So listen, this table is full of merch. There's CDs, and people are wearing subtle sexuality t-shirts. I was like, oh my gosh, where is all this? I wish I had a subtle sexuality t-shirt. Well, lady, I reached out to Joya about this.
他太温柔了。我只是很高兴他能出现在这个网络短剧里。我也是。所以听着，这张桌子上摆满了周边。有CD，人们都穿着“微妙性感”的T恤。我当时就想，天哪，这些东西都在哪儿？我也好想要一件“微妙性感”的T恤。好吧，天哪，我为此联系了乔娅。
She has all of the original subtle sexuality artwork. And last night, guess what I did? What? What did you do? What are you doing? Why are you taking off your sweatshirt? No, you didn't. No, you didn't. All right. Everybody gets a subtle sexuality t-shirt. I printed them. We used an ironing board. Josh helped me. We made everyone shirts. And Sam, I know you love collecting pop culture stuff. So you get a shirt and a pillowcase.
她拥有所有最初的“微妙性感”艺术作品。然后昨晚，你猜我做了什么？什么？你做什么了？你在干什么？你为什么要把卫衣脱掉？不，你没这么做。不，你没这么做。好吧。每个人都能得到一件“微妙性感”的T恤。我把它们印出来了。我们用了一个烫衣板。乔什帮了我。我们给每个人都做了衬衫。还有萨姆，我知道你喜欢收集流行文化周边。所以你得到了一件T恤和一个枕套。
Ooh, thank you. This is nuts. Oh my gosh. I love it so much. And they're different. You put different images. Yes, I had several images Joya gave me. And I can share these in our stories.
噢，谢谢你。这太疯狂了。天哪。我太喜欢了。而且它们还不一样。你印了不同的图案。是的，乔娅给了我好几张图片。我可以在我们的动态里分享这些。
It's so cool. I have Mindy as the pirate. This is nuts. This is why I have been wearing this big bulky sweatshirt because I had to cover the t-shirt. I have been sweating my butt off over here. I was so happy to finally take it off. Lady, I am going to say it right now.
太酷了。我这件是海盗造型的明迪。这太疯狂了。这就是为什么我一直穿着这件厚重的卫衣，因为我得把T恤遮住。我在这里都快热得出汗了。我太高兴终于把它脱掉了。天哪，我现在就要说：
This is your superpower. What you just did with these t-shirts and bringing it in for everyone, you're always bringing in gifts. This is do not let this go to live a normal life this year. Okay. Okay. Keep this going in this year. My party planning committee spirit going.
这就是你的超能力。你刚才用这些T恤做的事情，以及把它带给在场的每一个人，你总是给大家带礼物。这是……千万不要让这种特质在这个充满生活气息的一年里消失。好吧。好吧。今年要继续保持下去。我那颗“派对策划委员会”的心态还在。
Yes. I had to when I saw all of this artwork. I was like, this is so amazing. They really, really went for it. They really did. I just think they're fantastic. All right, so listen, now we're gonna have a series of talking heads where everyone is kind of reflecting on the popularity of their male prima donna hit.
对。当我看到所有这些艺术作品时，我情不自禁。我当时就想，这实在是太棒了。她们真的是太拼了。她们确实很拼。我只是觉得她们太棒了。好了，所以听着，接下来我们将会看到一系列的单人访谈，每个人都在反思他们的热门单曲《男名伶》所带来的巨大人气。
Yes. They're so funny. My favorite is Ryan's. I have to play it. Okay. There was a time where. I have to play it. OK. There was a time where everywhere I went in Scranton, I would hear, Mel Primadonna. I'd go to my mom's house and I'd hear Mel Primadonna.
对。她们太搞笑了。我最喜欢瑞恩的。我必须放给大家听。好吧。曾经有一段时间。我必须放给大家听。好吧。曾经有一段时间，我在斯克兰顿无论走到哪儿，都能听到：“男名伶”。我去我妈妈家，能听到“男名伶”。
I'd go to my dad's house and I'd hear Mel Primadonna. I'd go to Kelly's sister's house party. They would randomly be playing Mel Primadonna. Everywhere he went. Everywhere. My mom's house. Yeah, Mel Primadonna. Male Primadonna.
我去我爸爸家，能听到“男名伶”。我去凯莉姐姐家的派对。他们会随机播放“男名伶”。他去到哪里都能听到。到处都是。我妈妈家。对，“男名伶”。男名伶。
His delivery of it is so funny. I know. It's just so good. So good. Well, we're going to find out that things went south pretty quickly for this group. I guess there was a performance they thought was going to be at a record label turned out to be a record store. Yeah.
他唱这句时的语气太搞笑了。我知道。真的是太棒了。太棒了。好吧，我们要发现的是，这支组合的情况很快就开始急转直下了。我猜原本以为是一场唱片公司的演出，结果却变成了一家唱片店。对。
Security actually made them leave. Yeah, but that's not the only drama that befell the singers of male prima donna Angela. We now learn that they've kicked Andy out of the band. Yeah. Which Andy doesn't seem to know. Yeah. This is gonna be a surprise to him. Yeah Ryan says you know he doesn't know what it is but Andy didn't have it. Mm have it. So they got rid of him. And now Kelly and Erin are going to announce that, you know what? Despite all of this drama, they're moving forward with their new song, The Girl Next Door.
保安甚至把他们给赶出去了。对，但这还不是降临在《男名伶》歌手们身上的唯一戏剧性事件，安吉拉。我们现在得知，他们把安迪给踢出乐队了。对。而安迪对此似乎还一无所知。对。这对他来说会是一个惊喜。对。瑞恩说，你知道的，他具体说不上来是为什么，但安迪就是不行。嗯，就是没那种感觉。所以他们就把他给甩了。现在凯莉和艾琳要宣布，你知道吗？尽管经历了这一切风波，她们还是要带着她们的新歌《隔壁女孩》继续前行。
Yeah. Well, you know, Kelly, Erin, and Ryan kind of explain what The Girl Next Door is going to be. And you can also hear the fact that Andy is surprised that they've already been working on it. Let's hear it. The Girl Next Door is our new song that we're recording. And in the video, Kelly is the star.
对。好吧，你知道的，凯莉、艾琳和瑞恩大概解释了《隔壁女孩》会是一首什么样的歌。你还能听到安迪对于她们已经在筹备新歌感到十分惊讶。我们来听听。 《隔壁女孩》是我们正在录制的新歌。在这个MV里，凯莉是主角。
She is the girl next door. Yeah. I'm really excited. This is going to be a great video. She was also supposed to play the part of the Pretty Popular Girl, but Ryan doesn't have the technology to edit it that way. So they already shot it? I agree. It's weird for me to just play the everyday girl next door.
她就是那个隔壁女孩。对。我真的超级激动。这将会是一个很棒的MV。她本来还应该扮演那个“漂亮受欢迎的女孩”的角色，但瑞恩的技术水平不支持他那样剪辑。所以他们已经拍完了？我同意。让我来演这个普普通通的隔壁女孩感觉怪怪的。
But I'm a good actress. I play the jock that Kelly and Erin are both obsessed with. I actually studied with a private acting coach for three months to nail the role. I'm just playing. Clearly I didn for three months to nail the role. I'm just playing. Clearly I didn't have to reach all that far. I think we just recorded our next number one. AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH So that ends this making of documentary.
但我是个好演员。我扮演的是那个凯莉和艾琳都为之神魂颠倒的阳光体育生。我实际上跟私人表演教练学习了三个月才拿捏好这个角色。我开玩笑呢。显然我根本不用……学习三个月来拿捏这个角色。我开玩笑呢。显然我根本没花多大功夫。我想我们刚刚录制了我们的下一首冠军单曲。啊…………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………………所以这部幕后纪录片就到此结束了。
And next they released the song and music video, The Girl Next Door. Yes. It also had a huge marketing push from NBC. It had a Facebook page, which Joya told us she is still the admin for. She's like, I don't think NBC realizes that. She also sent me screen grabs of all of this stuff, of the Facebook pages,
接下来他们发布了这首歌和MV《隔壁女孩》。是的。NBC为此进行了大量的宣传推广。它甚至有一个Facebook页面，乔娅告诉我们她现在仍然是管理员。她说，我觉得NBC甚至都没意识到这一点。她还给我发了所有这些东西的截图，包括Facebook页面、
of comments that people left. I'm going to share it in our stories. The Girl Next Door website had pictures of Kelly, Erin, and Ryan. It also had dropdown tabs that said lyrics and credits, picks, free stuff, buy, fan club, and past projects. And it listed some thank yous. And I thought we could read them, Jenna. They're so funny.
人们留下的评论。我会在我们的动态里分享出来。 《隔壁女孩》的网站上有凯莉、艾琳和瑞恩的照片。它还有下拉标签，分别写着：歌词与鸣谢、照片、免费周边、购买、粉丝俱乐部以及过往项目。上面还列出了一些感谢名单。我觉得我们可以读一读，珍娜。它们太搞笑了。
Here's who Kelly would like to thank. Myself, for believing in me. Ryan Howard for the push all of the criticisms you gave me. Beyonce for being such a great role model. My sisters Ruka, Nipa, and Tiffany for nothing. Oh a little shade of the sisters. Yep. The VMA committee for selecting me as best new artist next year. And my stripper aerobics DVD for teaching me how to dance and look awesome. Amazing. And Erin had her own thank you section. Here is who she wanted to thank. Kelly Kapoor for letting me express myself through the song you wrote. Ellen DeGeneres for teaching me how to dance.
以下是凯莉想要感谢的人：我自己，感谢我自己相信我。瑞恩·霍华德，感谢你给我的推动以及你给我的所有批评。碧昂丝，感谢你成为这么好的榜样。我的姐姐们鲁卡、尼帕和蒂芬妮，谢谢你们什么都没做。哦，对姐姐们的一点暗讽。没错。VMA评委会，感谢你们提名我为明年的最佳新艺术家。还有我的脱衣舞有氧操DVD，感谢它教我如何跳舞并看起来帅呆了。太棒了。艾琳也有她自己的感谢环节。以下是她想要感谢的人：
Ryan Howard for being so nice. Andy Bernard for being so nice. Michael Scott for hiring me and giving me the best job in the world. That nice man that called the ambulance after I fell out of the tree. Thanks, whoever you are. Those were her thank yous. The website page also includes the following credits for the song. It says lyrics by Nate Federman and Jonathan Hughes. And the music was, once again, by Eve Nelson and also Raymond Servenka, published by Barter Music, Inc.
凯莉·卡普尔，感谢你让我通过你写的歌来表达自我。艾伦·德杰尼勒斯，感谢你教我跳舞。瑞恩·霍华德，感谢你这么好。安迪·伯纳德，感谢你这么好。迈克尔·斯科特，感谢你录用我并给了我世界上最好的工作。还有那个在我从树上摔下来后叫了救护车的善良陌生人。谢谢你，不管你是谁。这些就是她的感谢对象。网站页面还包含了这首歌的以下演职员鸣谢信息。上面写着：词作者为内特·费德曼和乔纳森·休斯。音乐则再次由伊芙·纳尔逊以及雷蒙德·塞尔文卡创作，由巴特音乐公司
and Exhibition Music, Inc. Yes, this music video was also directed by Mindy Kaling, and it was written by Kelly Hannon, Jonathan Hughes, and Mary Wall. I should have said before that that making of video, that was written by Kelly Hannon and Jonathan Hughes as well. And directed by Mindy. I think so.
和展览音乐公司发行。是的，这个MV同样由明迪·卡林执导，编剧则是凯莉·汉农、乔纳森·休斯和玛丽·沃尔。我之前应该说过，那部幕后视频，也是由凯莉·汉农和乔纳森·休斯编写的。并且由明迪执导。我想是的。
I couldn't find a credit for it, but I'm assuming directed by Mindy. Well, here is how the Girl Next Door video starts. Kelly is dressed in a pink zip-up hoodie with pink checkered fingernail polish. She's wearing glasses and her hair in sort of these long, low pigtails. They're in the kitchen break room at Dunder Mifflin. And she is playing checkers with Ryan, who is dressed in a letterman jacket. He's kind of got that jock look going. The opening credits say subtle sexuality featuring Rye Howard and then in quotations girl next door. The video
我找不到相关的演职员鸣谢，但我猜是明迪执导的。好吧，《隔壁女孩》的MV是这样开场的。凯莉穿着一件粉色拉链连帽衫，涂着粉色格纹指甲油。她戴着眼镜，头发扎成两束低低的双马尾。他们身处邓德米夫林的厨房茶水间里。她正在和穿着棒球夹克的瑞恩下跳棋。他身上有一种运动男孩的造型。开场字幕显示：微妙性感，由瑞恩·霍华德主演，后面加上引号“隔壁女孩”。这个视频
starts with a couplet of dialogue. Jenna, I think we should read it. You be Rye and I'll be Kelly. Okay, all right. This is me as Rye. So are you coming to my basketball game tonight? It's the state finals. Oh I don't think there's a bus stop by the sports dome. I don't know how I get there. Why don't I just pick you up? Oh okay. But wait everybody now Erin going to enter in a very sexy strapless party dress and she just kind of like struts past the table. Yeah. And, you know, Ry does a big double take at Erin and he gets up and he doesn't even look
开场是一段双人对话。珍娜，我觉得我们应该读一下。你演瑞恩，我演凯莉。好的，没问题。这是我演的瑞恩。那么你今晚来看我的篮球比赛吗？这是州决赛。哦，我觉得运动穹顶附近好像没有公交车站。我不知道怎么去那儿。要不我直接去接你吧？哦，好吧。等等，这时艾琳穿着一件非常性感的无肩带派对礼服登场了，她就那样从桌子旁大摇大摆地走过去。对。然后呢，瑞恩回头看了艾琳好几眼，他站起身来，甚至连看都没看
over her shoulder at Kelly. He just says bye and he goes after Erin. And then that's when the music video starts. The lyrics are so great. I think we need to hear the beginning. Let's do it. high self-esteem. People say that I could be a vaginal queen. We could be just like Juliet and Romeo, Cleopatra and Marc Anthony, or Marc Anthony and J-Lo. I'm just the girl next door, and she's totally bored. I wish I could be more
一眼身后的凯莉。他只说了一句“拜拜”就追着艾琳跑了。然后，MV就正式开始了。歌词写得太棒了。我觉得我们需要听听开头。我们开始吧。高自尊。人们说我可以成为阴道女王。我们可以像朱丽叶和罗密欧，克利奥帕特拉和马克·安东尼，或者马克·安东尼和詹妮弗·洛佩兹一样。我只是个隔壁女孩，而她完全无聊透顶。我希望我能成为更多……
I'm just the girl next door So catchy! Very catchy again. Yeah. In an interview with Vulture magazine, Mindy said it's a pop country song. She said there was elements of Carrie Underwood and Taylor Swift. And the video is based specifically on Taylor Swift's 2009 hit, You Belong with Me, in which Swift plays, as Mindy put it, both the girl next door and the hot bitchy girl. It's really amazing.
我只是个隔壁女孩……太洗脑了！真的很洗脑。是的。在接受《Vulture》杂志采访时，明迪说这是一首乡村流行歌曲。她说里面有凯莉·安德伍德和泰勒·斯威夫特的元素。而这个MV正是根据泰勒·斯威夫特2009年的热门单曲《You Belong with Me》改编的，正如明迪所说，斯威夫特在MV里既扮演了邻家女孩，又扮演了那个性感刻薄的女孩。这真的太神奇了。
I mean, the whole music video is just like Mindy sort of pining away for the popular guy who's completely obsessed with Erin. She's like rides a bicycle with the basket in the front. I love Mindy's look with this, the pigtails and the glasses and she's wearing this pink hoodie, but sometimes a yellow hoodie. She looks completely adorable.
我是说，整个MV就像是明迪一直在单相思那个完全对艾琳神魂颠倒的受欢迎男孩。她还骑着前面带车篮的自行车。我太喜欢明迪在这个MV里的造型了，扎着双马尾，戴着眼镜，穿着这件粉色连帽衫，有时候还会换成黄色连帽衫。她看起来简直太可爱了。
She looks so adorable. They do have a few outfit changes, but they're all in the same genre of their character. So Mindy has a few different hoodie looks, and Erin is in a few different types of cocktail dresses. And then Ryan has a few different letterman jackets. Yeah. My personal favorite shots are when
她看起来太可爱了。他们确实换了几个造型，但都在他们角色的同一种风格设定内。所以明迪换了几件不同的连帽衫造型，艾琳则穿着几款不同类型的鸡尾酒礼服。然后瑞恩换了好几件不同的棒球夹克。对。我个人最喜欢的镜头是
Mindy is singing behind the window, and it's like the rain is dripping down. But if you look beyond just the pane of glass that she's singing in front of, there's like no evidence of rain. It's like sunny in the parking lot and even the windows next to her. It's amazing. Let's not forget Ryan's other costume look is when he's dressed as an old man because guess what?
明迪在窗户后面唱歌，雨水顺着玻璃往下流。但如果你仔细看，透过她唱歌的那块玻璃往外看，外面根本没有下雨的迹象。停车场那边大晴天的，甚至连她旁边的窗户也是晴天的。这太绝了。别忘了瑞恩的另一个造型是当他扮成一个老头的时候，因为你猜怎么着？
He realizes he should have picked the girl next door. But it's too late. It's too late because guess what? She died of a broken heart. Yeah. He goes to her grave site. He leaves her a checker from the checkerboard. Yeah, from the checkerboard.
他意识到自己本该选择那个隔壁女孩。但已经太晚了。太晚了，因为你猜怎么着？她心碎而死了。对。他去了她的墓地。他在墓前留下了跳棋盘上的一枚跳棋。对，就是跳棋盘上的。
He remembers playing checkers with her. All I could think about was like all of the different prop items Phil Shea had to make. I know. He had to make a tombstone. He did. Did you notice there is this one part where Aaron is like making out with Ryan in front of Kelly's desk? And I don't know if you could tell, but I think it's really obvious that they are not actually kissing. They're not even touching. They're doing that real fakey kind of like
他想起了和她一起下跳棋的时光。我满脑子想的都是菲尔·谢伊不得不制作的那些各种道具。我知道。他不得不制作一块墓碑。他确实做了。你们注意到了吗，有这样一个片段，艾琳在凯莉的办公桌前和瑞恩亲热。我不知道你们能不能看出来，但我认为非常明显的是，他们其实根本没有在接吻。他们甚至连碰都没碰。他们做的是那种非常假惺惺的动作，
hands moving but their faces aren't touching. I have this whole backstory that it was because like Kelly didn't want Aaron and Ryan to really kiss in this music video. Oh absolutely not. It's very funny. Well Subtle Sexuality had a whole world tour lined up according to their website. No. Yeah. It started October 29th and went until November 8th. That's also when the webisodes were released.
手在动，但脸根本没贴在一起。我脑补了整个幕后故事，是因为凯莉不想让艾琳和瑞恩在这个MV里动真格地接吻。哦，绝对不可能。太搞笑了。好吧，《微妙性感》根据他们的网站显示，还安排了一整场世界巡演。不会吧。对。从10月29日一直持续到11月8日。这也是那些网络短剧发布的时间。
And they were mostly going to sing at karaoke bars and open mic nights. But around the world? No. Okay. Nope. But they were going to be the opening act at two events. Oh. On November 6, you could have found them headlining
他们基本上打算去卡拉OK酒吧和开放麦之夜唱歌。还是全球巡演？不是。好吧。没有。但他们将在两场活动中担任开场嘉宾。哦。在11月6日，你可以在
at Aaron's apartment. Oh. OK. And on November 7, they were in Ithaca, New York at Statler Hall opening for the Cayuga Waiters, which, by the way, Statler Hall is on Cornell University's campus. And the Cayuga Waiters were the campus' oldest all-mil acapella which, by the way, Statler Hall is on Cornell University's campus, and the Cayuga Waiters were the campus's oldest all-male acapella ensemble. They were
艾琳的公寓里看到他们作为头条嘉宾演出。哦。好吧。而在11月7日，他们将在纽约州伊萨卡市的斯塔勒大厅为卡尤加服务生乐队暖场，顺便说一句，斯塔勒大厅就在康奈尔大学的校园里。而卡尤加服务生乐队是该校历史最悠久的全男声阿卡贝拉……顺便说一句，斯塔勒大厅就在康奈尔大学的校园里，而卡尤加服务生乐队是该校历史最悠久的全男声阿卡贝拉合唱团。他们于
dismissed as a group in 2017 as an outcome of an investigation into hazing. Oh, that took a turn I wasn't expecting. Sorry, but I think at the time this was written they were... They had not been dismissed yet, is what you're saying. Exactly. Right, we were not promoting a group that hazes into their own dismissal. That's right. Got it.
2017年作为一个团体被解散了，这是针对校园霸凌事件调查的结果。哦，事情的发展走向有点出乎我的意料。抱歉，但我觉得写这段的时候他们……还没被解散，你是这个意思吧。没错，对的，我们可不是在宣传一个因为霸凌而导致自己被解散的团体。没错。明白了。
That was very liar liar of you, Angela. That was sort of keeping with Cassie's theme of the year. That was utter truth. Well, I just, of course, when I saw that they were gonna play at Statler Hall, I had to find out if it was a real place. Then I found out it was on Cornell. Then I found out that Cayuga Waiters
安吉拉，你这谎话连篇的功底可真厉害。这倒挺符合卡西今年的主题的。那可是彻头彻尾的真相。好吧，我只是……当然了，当我看到他们要在斯塔勒大厅演出时，我非得查查那是不是个真实的地方。然后我发现它在康奈尔大学。然后我又发现卡尤加服务生乐队
were an actual real acapella group. But then I- Until, until 2017. There was a little bit of a mom detective. It was, it sure was. I think it's a real kick in the nuts. I don't know, for Andy, that one of their tour stops was at his alma mater and he's not even in the band anymore. I have a feeling Andy... The poor guy.
真的是一支真正的无伴奏合唱团。但后来我……直到2017年。有点像妈妈神探。确实是。我觉得这对安迪来说真是一个沉重的打击。我不知道，对安迪来说，他们的巡演有一站竟然是在他的母校，而他甚至已经不在乐队里了。我有种预感，安迪……真可怜的家伙。
Yeah. I have a feeling Andy set it up. Oh, and now he doesn't even get to go. I know, because they kicked him out of the group. Wow. Lady, all of this music video stuff, it got me thinking, I was in a music video, and you were in a music video. I know, isn't that crazy? Being in music videos is super fun. Yeah. I was in a music video for the old 97s.
是啊。我有种预感是安迪安排的。哦，现在他甚至都不能去了。我知道，因为他们把他踢出了乐队。哇。女士们，所有这些音乐录影带的事情让我想起了我也拍过音乐录影带，你也在音乐录影带里出过镜。我知道，是不是很疯狂？拍音乐录影带超级好玩。对。我为旧97乐队拍过一部音乐录影带。
It was for their song, Good With God. It was actually directed by Lee. What'd you do in it? Well, I had this fun little moment at the top. We did one of these things, like they did with Girl Next Door, where there's like a scene that leads into the music video. Yeah. And it was starring me and Fred Armisen and the band.
那是为他们的歌《Good With God》拍的。实际上是由李执导的。你在里面演了什么？嗯，我在开头有一个很有趣的小插曲。我们做了一个这样的设计，就像他们在《邻家女孩》里做的那样，有一个场景引出音乐录影带。对。主演是我、弗莱德·阿米森和乐队。
Oh, wow. And so the premise was that I was going to be like interviewing the band for my music show called An Hour and 60 Minutes. And Fred was going to be like the stagehand who kept interrupting our interview and like doing comedy bit and distracting us from the interview.
哦，哇。所以设定是这样的，我要在一个名为《一小时又六十分钟》的音乐节目里采访这个乐队。而弗莱德要扮演那个不断打断我们采访、搞搞笑桥段并分散我们对采访注意力的舞台助理。
But here's the crazy thing that happened. When we showed up to film the video, the band, Old 97 said, we're so sorry, but our drummer, Philip Peoples, hurt his back. He couldn't fly in. He can't do the music video. Did Fred play the drums? Yes.
但接下来发生了一件疯狂的事。当我们到达片场准备拍摄时，旧97乐队说：“非常抱歉，我们的鼓手菲利普·皮珀斯背部受伤了。他飞不过来。他不能拍这个音乐录影带了。”弗莱德打鼓了吗？是的。
Because I know he plays drums. He's a drummer. He's really good. So we were like, how about we have Fred sit in as the drummer while you guys film this music video? So he did. So Fred is drumming in this music video for real. And then so for the top bit, we were like,
因为我知道他会打鼓。他是个鼓手。他非常厉害。所以我们就说：“让弗莱德顶替鼓手，你们拍这个音乐录影带怎么样？”于是他就这么做了。所以弗莱德真的在这支音乐录影带里打鼓。然后呢，对于开头的桥段，我们说：
how about the bit is that we ask Fred to sit in as the drummer and we say you don't have to say anything during the interview, but then Fred keeps answering the questions as if he's a band member and he sort of takes over the interview. It was really funny. It was so fun. What a great pivot. It was a lot of fun. But Fred is a good friend of ours. He was in Lee's movie Ordinary World. We know him.
桥段的设计是我们邀请弗莱德作为替补鼓手，我们说你在采访过程中不用说任何话，但接着弗莱德却像乐队成员一样回答问题，并且有点接管了采访。真的非常搞笑。太好玩了。多么棒的转变。非常有趣。不过弗莱德是我们的好朋友。他演过李的电影《平凡世界》。我们认识他。
Yeah. He's awesome. He could make me laugh reading the phone ours. He was in Lee's movie Ordinary World. We know him. Yeah. He's awesome. He could make me laugh reading the phone book. He's so funny. So funny. And of course, Rhett and the band are amazing. The old 97s. I mean, I love them.
对。他太棒了。他甚至能让我看着电话本笑出声来。他演过李的电影《平凡世界》。我们认识他。对。他太棒了。他甚至能让我看着电话本笑出声来。他太搞笑了。太搞笑了。当然，瑞特和乐队都太棒了。旧97乐队。我是说，我爱死他们了。
They're great. Well, mine wasn't as exciting as that. I was just like part of a crowd scene, you know? I've talked about this before. It was for Clay Walker's single, he's a country music artist, really nice guy. And there was a group of people that would sit around the stage, you know, as he played, but we're like out like, I feel like they were like bales of hay. It was supposed to look like country, like we're outside. Yeah. And it was filmed in New Mexico.
他们太棒了。好吧，我的可没那么令人兴奋。我只是人群背景的一部分，你知道的？我以前谈过这个。那是为克莱·沃克的单曲拍的，他是一位乡村音乐艺术家，人非常好。现场有一群人围坐在舞台周围，你知道的，当他演奏时，但我们就像是……我觉得我们看起来像干草捆。那是为了营造乡村的感觉，就像我们在户外一样。对。而且是在新墨西哥州拍摄的。
And I wore those. Remember when those- It was filmed in New Mexico. Did you get the job in LA and they traveled you to New Mexico? Oh no, I wasn't living in LA yet. I was living in Texas, but I had a friend who was working on it and was like, hey, we're gonna do a music video. Do you wanna come? And it's not that far of a drive.
我当时穿了那些。还记得那些——是在新墨西哥州拍摄的。你在洛杉矶找到了工作，然后他们安排你飞到新墨西哥州吗？哦不，我当时还没住在洛杉矶。我住在德克萨斯州，但我有一个朋友在那里工作，他说：“嘿，我们要拍一个音乐录影带。你想来吗？”而且开车过去并不算太远。
I have friends that I went to college with that lived in New Mexico. So anyway, I drove there and I was in this music video, but I wore my own clothes. Remember when it was fashion for people to wear construction boots? Yeah. Right, but I wore my own clothes. Remember when like it was fashion for people to wear like construction boots? Yeah. Right. But like with shorts. Yeah. I think that's still in fashion. Is it? Is it still in fashion? Is it that? Like the yellow construction boots? I think and I feel like maybe it is. Yeah. And then I wore like a sweater tucked into
我有上大学时的朋友住在新墨西哥州。不管怎样，我开车去了那里，我参演了这个音乐录影带，但我穿的是我自己的衣服。还记得当时人们穿工装靴是一种时尚吗？对。没错，但我穿的是我自己的衣服。还记得当时人们穿像工装靴这样的鞋子是一种时尚吗？对。没错。但搭配的是短裤。对。我觉得现在这还是时尚。是吗？这现在还是时尚吗？是那种吗？就像黄色的工装靴？我想，我觉得也许是的。对。然后我穿了一件塞进短裤里的毛衣。
shorts. What? But that's where you lost me. Yeah. I don't know if that was ever in. And then I wore like I would have done it. Chunky belt. Anyway, it was a look. And you can barely see me. I'm literally a blur. I'm sitting on like where the little concert was with a group of people and we're like singing along with Clay and the camera pans past us, but it's like a blur. And it was his song,
什么？但这就是你把我绕晕的地方。对。我不知道这是否曾经流行过。然后我穿得就像我会做的那样。一条宽腰带。不管怎样，那是一种造型。而且你几乎看不到我。我简直就是一个模糊的影子。我就坐在那个小演唱会所在的地方，和一群人在一起，我们跟着克莱一起唱歌，镜头从我们身边扫过，但看起来像是个模糊的影子。那是他的歌，
If I could make a million out of loving you, I'd be a millionaire in a week or two. I love that song. I'd be doing what I love and love and what I do. Now lady. It's a great song. Did you get paid? Is it your first like professional on-camera gig?
如果我能靠爱赚到一百万，我一两周内就能成为百万富翁。我喜欢那首歌。我会做我爱的事，爱我所做的事。现在，女士。这是一首好歌。你拿到报酬了吗？这是你的第一份专业镜头前工作吗？
If it was pre LA? Is this your Jurassic Park water ride moment? Yes. Was dancing repeatedly to this song? Yes, this is my first entertainment gig. Wow. Clay Walker. There you have it.
如果是在去洛杉矶之前？这是你的《侏罗纪公园》水上游乐设施时刻吗？是的。是在这首歌里反复跳舞吗？是的，这是我的第一份娱乐行业工作。哇。克莱·沃克。就是这样。
If you literally blink, you'll miss me. Yeah. I'm barely in it. Well, before we go, everybody, we did have some fans send in a bullsh** card about this whole episode series. Oh, bullsh** card. Yeah. Let's hear it.
如果你眨一下眼，就会错过我。对。我几乎没在里面。好了，在我们结束之前，各位，确实有粉丝针对整个番外剧集系列寄来了一张胡扯卡。哦，胡扯卡。对。让我们听听。
You mentioned it in our intro. Fans said they think it's crazy that Kelly, Ryan, and Aaron were in a band that made two music videos and this fact never made it into an actual episode of the show. Oh yeah. I agree with this bulls**t card. Same. I mean, if Toby's radon runner can make it for years, why couldn't subtle sexuality have a moment in the series? I agree. And listen, finally, in researching this webisode, I found the most amazing fan tribute video. It's phenomenal.
你在开场白里提到了。粉丝们说，他们觉得凯莉、瑞安和亚伦曾在一个创作了两首音乐录影带的乐队里，而这个事实竟然从未出现在剧集的正片中，这太疯狂了。哦，是的。我同意这张胡扯卡。我也是。我是说，如果托比的氡气检测员可以存在好几年，为什么“微妙性感”乐队不能在剧里拥有高光时刻呢？我同意。而且听着，最后，在研究这个网络番外时，我找到了最精彩的粉丝致敬视频。太惊艳了。
A group of women hired a professional videographer and they recreated the male prima donna music video shot by shot. They even have on the costumes. They have all the dance moves. It is such an achievement. We have to share it. We have to put it in our stories. I was riveted. It's very special. It made me want to do it. It made me want to do this, like with a group of friends, like pick a music video you love and just go for it. Recreate it. Yes. Shot by shot. Yeah.
一群女性雇了一个专业摄像师，一镜不差地重现了男版绝代佳人的音乐录影带。她们甚至穿着戏服。她们有着所有的舞蹈动作。这真是一项伟大的成就。我们必须分享它。我们必须把它发到我们的动态里。我当时看得入迷了。这非常特别。这让我也想去做了。这让我想要这样做，和一群朋友一起，选一个你喜欢的音乐录影带然后全力以赴。重现它。是的。一镜不差。对。
Ah, all right, well, everyone, there you have it. That's our breakdown of subtle sexuality. And before we go, yesterday was World Cancer Day. And I'd like to mention an initiative that I'm supporting called Screening Time Off. I am so glad you're doing this. Well, I think you guys know my breast cancer was discovered during a routine mammogram and ultrasound.
好了，好吧，各位，就是这样。这就是我们对“微妙性感”的剖析。在我们离开之前，昨天是世界癌症日。我想提及一个我正在支持的倡议，叫做“筛查请假时间”。我很高兴你能做这件事。好吧，我想你们知道我的乳腺癌是在例行乳房X光检查和超声波检查中发现的。
I had been putting them off because, well, it's annoying, trying to find time for cancer screenings and doctor's appointments. But luckily, I went when I did. My cancer was found early and it was treatable. But if I had waited a few months longer, things could have been way worse. And caught early, many cancers have survival rates
我之前一直拖延，因为，好吧，这很烦人，要努力腾出时间去做癌症筛查和预约医生。但幸运的是，我在那个时候去了。我的癌症发现得很早，而且是可以治疗的。但如果我再多等几个月，情况可能会变得更糟。如果尽早发现，许多癌症的生存率
well over 90%. However, most people don't prioritize their recommended screenings. And one of the biggest reasons why is because they can't get time off work. Yeah. So that's why I'm trying to get the word out about the Screening Time Off program, which encourages employees to take time to step out for screenings by asking employers
远超90%。然而，大多数人并没有把推荐的筛查放在首位。其中最大的原因之一是他们无法请到假。对。所以这就是为什么我试图宣传“筛查请假时间”项目，该项目鼓励员工通过要求雇主
to join Screening Time Off to take the pledge that you will let your employees off to get these screenings. This seems like such a no-brainer. To let your employees be proactive in their health. Yes, so get your screenings everyone. And if you would like to be the world's best boss, do you see what I did there? I do.
加入“筛查请假时间”项目来腾出时间进行筛查，承诺允许员工请假去进行这些筛查。这似乎是一个不需要动脑筋就能做出的决定。让员工对自己的健康采取积极主动的态度。是的，所以大家都要去做筛查。如果你想成为世界上最好的老板，你们看到我刚才的梗了吗？我看到了。
You can learn more and sign up at WorkingWithCancerpledge.com. I'll share all of that in our stories. Well, thank you everyone for listening and a big thank you to Nate Fetterman and Joya Balfour for sending us so much great stuff about this episode. Yes, and thank you to my husband Josh, who last night helped me iron on these decals onto shirts.
你可以访问WorkingWithCancerpledge.com了解更多信息并进行注册。我会在我们的动态里分享所有这些。好吧，非常感谢大家的收听，也要非常感谢内特·费特曼和乔亚·巴尔福给我们发来关于这一集的那么多精彩内容。是的，还要感谢我的丈夫乔希，他昨晚帮我把这些贴纸熨烫到衬衫上。
And you know, one last thing that Joya shared with us was that there was a Mel Prima Donna remix version. It's super fun and I think we should hear it as we go to credits. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
你知道的，乔亚跟我们分享的最后一件事是，还有一个“男版绝代佳人”的混音版本。超级好玩，我想我们在播放职员表时应该听一听。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audience的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。
Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubberree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯·伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubberree》。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。